retour on est de retour envergure le
live youtube merci à la first team café
le la première partie avec nous et qui
nous permet de rester chez eux là dans
leurs beaux studios
donc ça va être génial on va pouvoir
suivre toute la fin de cette draft avec
vous avec également le chat
on attend vos réactions vos questions on
a raté un petit pic pendant qu'on est
con pendant qu'on était absent mathis
style choisi par les boston celtics
fruits ndi manu houben un des deux jeux
jeux spécifié mathis talbot a été tuée d
à delphi en retour du pq 24 et 33 ou et
je salue mollon la béquille masse
traités pendant une heure sur twitter
pour me dire que mathis triebold devrait
pas aller à philadelphie maintenant il
est la ville à delphi moellons et tu vas
apprendre à l'aimer chez le promu
[Rires]
philadelphie donc pour mathis style tu
m'as dit que c'était contre le 24 et le
30 3 bénin le 24 et le 30 3 il ya un
échange pour le pic suivant aussi au
club doit sentir et que la 23 mêmes fils
arrive à 21 et mes fils regard de rien
la restriction de brendan cole même fils
à 21 et 24 33 pour boston mathis 'table
à boston
manu qu'est ce que tu penses de matisse
title à boston qui est très ému on le
voit à l'image
sinon fishers a aussi aussi que c'est un
peu n'importe quoi excusez-moi aux
sixers
le cool parce qu'il va apporter des deux
côtés du terrain
défensivement c'est l'un des meilleurs
potentiels de cette draft
il a montré sur sa saison à washington
qui pouvaient chuter aussi à l'extérieur
et les sixers ont besoin de shooting ont
besoin de ce pays signe notamment avec
ben times
donc pour m'asseoir un bon pique pour
moi c'est un bon piqué le l'échangé
peut-être un peu fort de lâcher deux
pics pour monter comme ça mais je pense
que ça intéressant ils disent que c'est
bon le son ça va vous nous dites sur le
chat si ça va pas bien sûr le son là on
me demande un petit peu si si c'est bon
pour vous
jouer psychologiquement nous dit parfait
la qualité donc donc ça a l'air d'être
d'être pas mal
ben tahar action sur ta gueule moi moi
j'aime bien fait de lui un joueur dont
on doute des capacités offensives mais
faut se mettre en contexte que la
dernière année mais tout d'abord il a vu
lever tous à washington il va être
on va le caler dans un rôle bien claque
là depuis il va il va être joueur
complémentaire votre rôle est vraiment
très très agressif qui est vraiment à
l'image de l'équipe et est ce que tu
peux parler de sa manie chc une surprise
aussi haut par les spurs
ça sent le style quand même pas je pense
qu'on était tous d'accord
quand je vois que personne mbc est le
cas cette année je suis un joueur qui a
un bon potentiel offensif mais qui qui
qui est très grand et très qui bouge un
peu mal défensivement et je vois pas
vraiment ce que ce que je sais les
pourris spurs veulent enfin moi j'aurais
juré donner un bon 2 en arriver mais il
va être à san antonio l'année prochaine
et je sais pas comment c'est étonnant
parce que c'est pas un pic selon le to
you compatibles là c'est un joueur qui
va qui a déjà réputé pour avoir un
mental et pas forcément super cool donc
là ils vont devoir le faire travailler
je sais je sais pas trop je trouve pas
que ça ressemble trop à un san antonio
après ils ont san antonio ne doivent
jamais un joueur ressent
des certitudes sûrement la personnalité
l'interview a dû être réussi ce
forcément dire qu'il a dû plaire à gregg
popovich hitchcock tu puisqu'on parlait
autrefois du coup en s'amusant que le un
joueur des spurs doit avoir un peu de
rire de soi je vibrais de l'auto
dérision et l'autodérision dérision on
rigolait goût comme quoi c'est un match
qu'on n'avait pas forcément
bah faut croire que si on nous demande
on connaît la contrepartie de memphis
thunder ben ils ont juste swaps et les
piquer quoi même ficelle donné quoi en
plus pour l'instant on n'en sait pas
plus sur la table au camas et silva il
va ya donné un deuxième pic 2024 à
oklahoma city
donc c'est vraiment un serment qu une
formalité là c'est juste pour dire
qu'ils ont donné quelque chose de plus
pour avancé de 2,1 ok on peut pas vous
mettre on est désolé on vous met on vous
actualise déjà là avec les joueurs et
les points forts points faibles on peut
pas vous mettre le tableau de la draft
en même temps on est désolé sur sur le
live youtube on va essayer de vous faire
des points récapitulatif le plus souvent
possible le choix 19 est parti aux spurs
s'étaient luca sam and each le joueur
croate qui a un fort potentiel qui est
encore jeune et qui s'est un petit peu
tout faire le vin a été choisi par
boston mais par à philadelphie qui
envoyait en échange les pics 24 et 33
on a l porthos manu qui nous demandent
est-ce que c'est choquant que ball vol
ne soit pas encore drafté pour moi non
parce que moi c'est pas un joueur sur
lequel j'attends j'ai peur déjà avec sa
blessure au pied
pour moi c'est pas c'est pas super
rassurant quand les grands sont touchés
au pied comme ça et pour moi c'est pas
un joueur qui est bien compatible il a
le morphotype de son père vraiment très
très fin très très long il a montré
quelques belles choses notamment sur des
contres ou east
je suis plus content qu'ils s'étaient
saint john au droit où il est par terre
ils arrivent à se relever super vite les
scotcher le shooter à trois points mais
je sais pas pour moi j'en parle un peu
en rigolant je le compare un peu à javel
maggie c'est eux c'est une grande tige
qui est en toi il va faire la joie du
shaq qu'ils ne foulent fenêtre peut-être
pas mais chez moi je suis passé pas
forcément le le joueur que j'irai que
j'irai chercher si je fais une équipe
nba
ouais après bubble ball néanmoins on
l'avait tous top 10 en début de l'année
c'est un potentiel de fouet absolument
je voudrais le ciel est sky is the limit
pour lui à amadouer memphis vient
d'officialiser bonne claque
donc c'est bien alors c'est bien leur
pic mais oui c'est un potentiel de fou
c'est juste que il ya de multiples red
flag la personnalité c'est peut-être
parce qu'un de ses pieds qui n'aime pas
vraiment joué au basket on le sait pas
c'est quelqu'un qui elle est même passée
cours qui avaient des poids me passer
match ou au lycée c'est vraiment
inquiétant les yeux blessures et le cas
lorsqu'il a subi sa blessure il tant que
disparu la carte vietto recrutons
retombées du monde est vivant on savait
pas trop trop ou et qui nous est ce
qu'il était qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient
et il est revenu très loin car en
pantalon de sport ce qui était vraiment
dans sa cachette qui cache une blessure
donc c'est vraiment pas étonnant que ce
soit pas de rater ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'il parte dans les prochains dans les
prochain pic mais ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'il parte
financer une deuxième qui glisse
beaucoup
donc même fils vient de draft et brandon
clark
j'adore clairement oui moi je vais être
très clair jahren jackson junior brandon
clark jah maurenn tu as la mène des
shooteurs autour même fils nouvelle
équipe league pass ben oui c'est ce que
j'allais faire cesser c'est clairement
mon league pass numéro 1 pour l'année
prochaine seront ils vont être bonnes
chances pour pour les affronter ils vont
jouer rapidement et ont joué de manière
rude très très hâte d'avoir cette
nouvelle mouture 2010 alors ben on
j'ai demandé alors dites nous dans le
chat mais les gens préfèrent
éventuellement ne pas être spoilé donc
on attend à des accords ont dit qu'on
attend adam silver même si toi tu le
sais avant moi je regarde pas twitter la
non mais c'est rien mais c'est juste
j'ai demandé les gens préfèrent qui est
pas de spoil c'est vrai que si on le
découvre nous nous on n'a pas twitter
avec manu là antoine va revenir et on
nous demandait si roanne et thomas
étaient là ils sont en train de boire du
rhum la trainière le rhum mais mais
voilà brandon clark manu tu aimes bien
aussi ouais j'aime bien je trouve que
c'est un joueur que qui vieux ok mais il
est même il a pas mal d'expérience c'est
un jour que fort sur le physique capable
de contrer mais moi j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup à ma vie je pense que
memphis a fait une super draft isa ils
sont dans la reconstruction complète
moi j'aime beaucoup ce qu'ils font pour
l'instant ouais je suis d'accord avec
toi manu je crois que c'est une
reconstruction complète mais qui
s'arrêtent son équipe qui va
compétitionner à chaque soir l'année
prochaine ça sera pas avec le coeur pas
absolument ce ne sera pas la honte que
avec les mecs l'année dernière je n'aime
pas trop ça mais ça va être des défaites
encourageantes non c'est clair mais et
mais il va y avoir des vétérans des
décodeurs des cas avec eux des jonas
siggi va donc s'en remettra
intéressant je crois on est en train de
regarder romain il représente tellement
sur le plateau de bin si vous avez
l'image essayer de mettre l'image biner
et nous les séances ont parce que quand
même on est là on est là mais il donne
des petits coups qu'il a nos chouchous
sont pas encore tombés un ben si on
doute kabengele nicolas claxton on les
attend ils étaient dans la green room
pourtant mois après c'était une green
room en peu étendu mais six ans little
qui ont toujours pas parti nassir little
qui est toujours caché à cha cha cha ca
le deuxième tour pour les kabengele
lugentz dorthe nation layton croit qu'il
va prendre
il va trouver vraiment avoir la fin de
ce premier tour là je crois que si on
aime states is it encore là au choix de
golden state qui vont se sauver avec la
banque
oui absolument et là là ça sent les
styles à venir 1 je suis désolé mais non
mais moi j'ai l'impression que que là ça
sent quand même les styles à venir alors
attention puisque non j'allais dire adam
silver arrive mais il n'arrive pas le
pic 22 c'est du coup je suis
complètement perdue boston ces bosses
aussi encore beau jardin ouais c'est
boston donc boston a draftés pour
l'instant seulement romeu langford
puisqu'ils ont transféré le picte 20
donc là ils vont drafté 22 24 et 33
ouais ok donc là peut-être que c'est ça
remplit la ferme mais oui exactement
l'équipe de geely qui va être au complet
les prochaines un peu plus peut-être
pour les gens du chat cause peut-être
pas forcément brandon clark ben c'est un
joueur sur le son profil c'est un joueur
incroyable
ah oui c'est un athlète ce poste 4 qui
va jouer
post5 small ball nba c'est à peu près ce
ch est incroyable il est rapide il est
explosif
il est très doué défensivement il est
capable de switch off plusieurs
positions je voudrais pas être de 3 à 5
et et c'est un finisseur au cercle
vraiment vraiment très agressif je crois
qu'il est dans l'adn de memphis à 100
milles à l'heure ce sera pas les bruits
taiwan mais ça va être quelque chose
avec une évolution de ceux de ce concept
l'année prochaine oui absolument
absolument donc une équipe de memphis
qui va régaler l'année prochaine qui est
ce que tu vois boston
alors peut-être que toi tu as le spoiler
manu alors plutôt qu'est ce que tu vois
à boston la pièce que tu verras bien sûr
le chat on annonce nasir little pourquoi
pas un meneur n'y en a pas pour hbo s'il
y en a mais ils soient annoncés plus bas
à prendre une surprise près sûr mais
c'est vrai quand même bénin way back and
johnson aaron je me remettrai jamais là
c'est clair cameron johnsons
on l'attendait au mais pas ton bon c'est
mes mecs mais cas quand j'ai eu le
spoiler sur twitter je n'attendais que
votre réaction légal c'est vrai m
comment foule attendait que votre
réaction
le pic le pays est rentré pour le boss
mais le pic est rentré donc tu vas
attendre notre réaction au 6 mai
absolument
pour l'instant on en est au pic 21 qui
qu'est ce que tu vois un peu vainqueur
de cette draft là si on commence à
prendre du recul même fils comme manu
tantôt à une draft absolument incroyable
sinon les pelleteuses qui ont fait
fructifier leur pic c'est l'ailé les
attentes étaient mauvaises du tout donc
ces trois équipes là je pense qu on
vraiment se sont également démarquées
absolument le perdant se drape c'est le
coaster de bois le bol le perdant de la
draft quelques stars de volley-ball
clairement et celui de tyler est aussi
un parti en 13 avec une tapisserie avec
des défunts de rideau de chez saint
maclou là c'était pas piquée des
hannetons messieurs tu l'avais celle là
comme expression canada ben tâche est
magnifique non pas du tout donc on va on
va arriver vers la fin de ce premier
tour qui sont vos joueurs préférés qui
restent les gars qui sont vos styles un
petit peu manu des siens little nasir
little pour toi là c'est sur ton board
c'est le meilleur joueur disponible ben
à adam si adam silver attend ben gray
and william aux boston celtics avant
nasir little avant kevin porter juniors
avant plein de gens qui paraissent avoir
plus de potentiel est encore un mec qui
joue qui joue sur les postes 3 4 quoi
finalement ils les empile les uns par le
sud par dessus les autres ben daniels
qu'est-ce qui fait belle histoire c'est
que marx maurice devrait quitter mais là
on a avec un tollé autour d'un joueur
qui est dans l'adn de baston qui est
inquiet dur qui est polyvalent qui sait
s'adapter à plusieurs situations donc
moi je crois que germes t'aime bien
et oui oui absolument et je crois que la
seule date en janvier peut-être au p 24
tu penses tu penses que là ils vont
drafté foule ailier quoi sert un côté il
vente est william ce little et on voit
qu'ils ont on jette on les jette et puis
on voit qui c'est qui ressort pendre la
langue fon je crois qu'il va jouer un
poste 2 ils vont peut-être même
l'essayer en poste oui
mais pour les deux jean troué c'est
clair que port au prince william si vous
jouez un ailier fort mais peut-être
qu'ils vont essayer ils vont s'essayer
avec bâle bol ou si on sait pas je vous
ramène suppose pour l'heure avec ça mais
pour moi avec avec ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine à bostens il n'y a pas de
débat de mauvais choix
ouais y'a pas de mauvais choix mais bon
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas trop de meneurs
disponible mais est-ce que drafté alors
peut-être qu'il projette de faire jouer
grant wood ian 104 manu finalement ce
serait étonnant et un peu kouyou quand
même parce que j'ai eu il a le physique
je pense il est temps qu est il et où
bhl argile et solide sur ses appuis mais
résister à des quatre régulièrement et
de façon aux comptes
ultra bol ce patch est malheureux non je
sais pas si c'est vraiment le rôle qui
lui convient le mieux pour moi c'est
plus un mec qui porte la balle c'est un
grand grand 1 en fait ouais capable
vraiment de d'attaquer le panier de
faire des patchs je ne souhaites tu le
vois pas comme tout le monde s'intéresse
au web à madame est servie la vision de
jeu qui qu'il a ça en lui en fait c'est
un peu une et c'est ce qu'on en parlait
un peu tout à l'heure du coup mais je
pense je trouve qu'il a ça en lui chez
moi je le vois plus 102,3 cancan 3,4 en
fait
alors on fait un petit récap pour les
gens qui suivent le live uniquement
audio et qui n'ont pas le récap sous les
yeux on va repartir du pic 18 avec gogh
habitat d opers le 19 c'est elle ou
cassama nietzsche à san antonio chez les
spurs
le vin c'était notre ami te retrouves ta
maison du style qui va à philadelphie
puisque boston a traîné son pic quand
phil fasan contre philadelphie
brandon clark avec le 21 va à memphis ce
n'est plus oklahoma city mais ces mêmes
fils il ya eu un échange on ne connaît
toujours pas la contrepartie ben de cet
échange entre memphis et oklahoma city
de ce que j'ai lu juste un deuxième
temps un pic de deuxième tour en 2024
juste avant ces deux pour s'assurer
finalement brandon clark
et donc brandon clark en 21 et grant
williams 122e qui aidera paraît donc par
les boston celtics c'est donc au tour du
thunder de draft et le thunder manu il
ya besoin de shoot comme d'habitude
comme depuis shooter depuis longtemps
longtemps et cherche quelqu'un de
vraiment très très bon poste de vraiment
quelqu'un de constant au poste 2 ouais
bon là ils ont pris un pote george mais
pour moi qui est plus inquiet +13
bottled jorge luis c'est un poste très
bon et ça fait des années en plus landry
roberson s'était blessé pour placer
hamidou diallo tehran gusen qui joue
deux ces derniers temps dans la saison
dernière donc moi je les vois bien un 2
duo 1
je sais pas 1 1 kevin porter ou qu'elle
donne johnson ça me tue jamoye faire un
pari toi ça me choquerait pas prêts
qu'elles donnent 20 paris ils ont pas
forcément besoin d'un joueur qui va
apporter comme ils ont quand même aux
usa heureuse ou arras elwes brook podor
steven adams andré roberson qui va
revenir qui va apporter sa défense
donc ils n'ont pas besoin d'un mec qui
va apporter beaucoup beaucoup et
instantanément comme ça des one et
tirades ferguson n'a pas été si mauvais
que ça il avait il a fait des belles
parties
absolument rien donc ouais 1 2 ou
peut-être 1,4 voire 1,5 ça dépend ce que
ce qui vous faire devenir heinz ol
j'ai pas son son contrat lie la durée de
son contrat s'il est free agent ou pas
je sais pas trop donc ouais 12.45 -
luigi sur le chat qui nous dit porteur
du junior en 23 antoine qui est de
retour ça va ça va crétier oklahoma city
dont quatre étaient déjà ton avis sur le
trait d'aller chercher brandon clark
pour memphis tu dis tu dis oui
jackson avec audi jon jackson ça fait
deux bons contraire cadre là ça va
bouger c'est vers quoi
et pas bon traîner dans la quête d'eux
mêmes ficelles prochaine ouais niveau
pas après le potentiel est un peu limité
mais bon et je suis lié nier une bonne
éthique de travail et de ça peut pousser
les autres vers le haut quoi le coup
tant que jeune joueur j'aime assez après
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont donné pour le
pic 21 ils ont donné le pic 23 plus un
deuxième tour d'une année prochaine
disait ben ok ouais ça va ça passe pas
trop quoi c'est pas trop effectivement
on nous demande aussi ben on nous
demande pourquoi nasirli talent est
descendu au temps c'est pas trop ce que
moi je crois que pour montrer rien de
concret à ayew ainsi pour montrer à quoi
y étaient bons offensivement il ya des
facilement non plus donc je crois qu'il
a laissé les équipes sur le rapide si
pas mal
ouais bah oui c'est une excellente
athlète mais mais j'ose dire c'est bon
c'est pourquoi est ce que nous donner
ouais il ya plein de choses qu'on l'a
dit il a fait une très mauvaise saison
il faut quand même le rappeler on l'a
peut-être pas assez rappelé parce qu'il
a fait des bonds workout parait-il
mais cette saison ce terme un peu
catastrophique notamment défensivement
on avait l'impression que c'était un
petit faon qu'ils étaient perdus
this is forty quoi un pic 23 qui arrive
à darius beazley
oklahoma du coup à un poème a du coup
effectivement donc c'est à la base
c'était le pic du jazz qui est ensuite
parti à quelque part même fils et qui
est ensuite parti à oklahoma je crois
que c'est ça cet ordre là darius beazley
antoine of ba ba jelade hors jeu là dort
pas il pas une forme ward pas par un
shooter par red river mais qu'est une
vraie palette de move est qui qui peut
dijoux
ou au poulet quelques jeunes qui est qui
est long j'aime beaucoup mais niro
sender bas au thunder peut-être pour la
création mais c'est vrai que toi au
thunder le ballon est dans la main de
westbrook est intéressant manu c'est pas
le meilleur environnement pour lui le
thunder bah c'est le prototype du joueur
capable de tout faire comme disait
antoine le point fort dit il répond pas
trop aux attentes du thunder ouais ben
tu partages la vie nos camarades 2 pas
loin avec son bep juste à côté et je
l'avais je la vends 27 personnellement
je l'aimais bien aux honnêtes mais que
ces morceaux sous la cohabitation qui
passe quelque chose mais ça fait ça fait
d'autres créations ça fait un je ne sais
pas si c'est un une
c'est un environnement qui est propice à
son évolution en tant que joueur mais je
pense qu'il est beaucoup trop talentueux
pour prouver pour échouer tuer et je
tiens à dire aussi que c'est une autre
histoire de réussite des richpoi le tu
parles place ses pions dans la nba
manuge magnifiquement ouais c'est vrai
avec garlande qui est pas ce qu'est
parti en cinq parties relativement tôt
darus base les c'est vrai que le les
joueurs sous la croupe soula sous la
croûte
est-ce que je peux mentionner les
échanges vas-y ben parle-nous par le new
day trade ce peuple est il y a les
bostons aurait échangé numéro 24 à
phoenix à phoenix qui veut sauver sa
draft
après
et contre tout couac en quoi c'est pas
dit encore ces jeux ouattara si je
sortis la semaine tu seras notre vote ce
soir c'est toi qui va nous dire un petit
peu les traits de ce qui se passe et
c'est à nous nouons ier spillane devant
nous la à l'image donc là c'est la pub
ça meubles pas mal énormément de pub
nous on vous montre darus basly
peut-être qu'on pourra essayer de mettre
autre chose à l'image on pourra ou pas
tu penses
bah je sais pas s'il ya pas les plus ou
moins values sont surtout les joueurs en
bas ça est un peu compliqué mais mais
sinon je pense pourquoi pourquoi boston
trèbes le pic c'est qu'à mon avis ils
voulaient basly en 24 à oui je pense
qu'ils ont très donne 24 ans se disant
bon on va choper le 33 ans + basly on
est tranquille on peut le prendre en 24
je pense pas de bol ouais je pense que
c'est beaucoup pas de bol c'est pas de
bol qui est toujours pas pris d'ailleurs
dit en passant il ya toujours pas de bol
fx est toujours là il attend nasir
little c'est pareil kevin porter d'union
c'est pareil nicolas claxton c'est
pareil moundou kabengele c'est pareil
tout ça c'est le cas des normes
[ __ ] mais c'est va y avoir de la green
room certaine au second tour bon certes
un klaxon qui va finir aux spurs lilian
qu'est venu dans live l'autre fois
qu'ils nous disent à lui et qui espère
un gros coucou pour portland qui piquent
en 25
donc c'est la dent dans cinq minutes et
c'est vrai qu'il reste pas mal de
joueurs intéressants
alors si il ya plusieurs fans de
portland sur le chat dites nous qui est
ce que vous espérez un petit peu avec ce
pic 25 et vu les gens qui restent year
one qui a sorti le rosé oh [ __ ] il est
vrai ou pas ils ont pris ce vrai mais
ils gardent les mains
et puis tu en plus c'est une grosse faim
[ __ ] il est frais il est frais je peux
vous dire que c'est à faire la fête ici
ça me recevoir et celle ci peut importe
les sommes sont n'importe quoi dit
manitou pourquoi tu veux spoiler brésil
vas-y spoil abattant il arrive
est-ce qu'il arrive en fait le seul
c'est là il est là si le pic 24 la la
c'est le pic 25 ans fait les pics 24 a
été changé à boston et boston méchant
jaf fait en fait à phoenix ont classé
les suns qui les services critiques et
ils choisissent on se moque du rhum
c'est un bon joueur est tellement vous
en parle là mais pour les félix qu'est
ce que tu fais il monte une équipe de nc
y avait visiblement l'année prochaine
phoenix a va y avoir du shoot james
joyce tu fais mais après moi j'aime bien
cette germain c'est un bon joueur mais
ce que je sais c'est pas fini car en nba
parce que là là clairement c'est ce
qu'on attend de lui visiblement c'est un
éternel role players en nba jam est elle
est là et là comment tu le vois le bac
courte tête jérôme des vignes booker
défensivement ben c'est une belle
réponse et une belle réponse je sais pas
je supporte sur toute question donnée
pour avantager le sait si c'est une
honte de commencer avec l'effectif 063
avoir des restos revenir à la maison
avec avec tyrone et ben johnson s'est
attaché pour la route le gym john james
georges quoi qu'il a apporté une
bouteille de rhum l'incident sans
pouvoir la soirée chez risque c'est
assez terrible cette draft des suns
peut-être qu'on se trompe peut-être que
on mangera notre chapeau on boira notre
homme rétrospectivement way
j'attends la bouteille de rosé c'est que
c'est pas des joueurs à développer en
fait non
si je finis bah ouais mon cd produit
quasiment une équipe jeune après
d'evenko kurt a envie de le garder donc
je suis les gardes tu le gardes avec sa
version perso j'adore un tel job c'est
vrai ce que laissait dont ils ont besoin
est ce que tu peux avoir mieux puis 24
suis pas su pas si sûr que ça mais moi
les pirates clarke ceo mirel du est ce
qu'ils ont donné des envies
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont donnée puis il
c'est vrai qu'il reste c'est pas du
nasir little moi j'achète avec du rhum
et mimi juge parce qu'ils ont donnée
pour ça alors dit nous pourquoi tu
achètes tide jérôme déjà rapidement bas
parce que c'est un simple poste 1 2 et
il a des bras les plus petits de
l'histoire de l'humanité
je pense que voilà 1,91 d'envergure
ouais c'est un quatre ans d'envergure il
un différentiel il a il a deux pouces et
demi de d'écart entre s'attelle à éros
héros il a un pouce d'écart on est en
négatif est tight jérôme il a deux
pouces et demi d'écart entre cette
taille et son envergure
donc c'est son envergure et deux pouces
et demi plus petite que sa taille c'est
le record all time de tous les prospects
qui sont jamais passés par le combiné
des mesures officielles et on nous dit
sun the really think holly johnson
jérôme et dario saric break qu'il avait
le peak 6 mai ouais c'est pas une
gestion
idéal des échanges en tête tu es change
pas un las acacias pas de valeur ce
qu'ils ont fait croire ce qu'ils ont
pris je suis curieux à moi basile et
humaine jugé que savoir qu'est ce qu'ils
ont donné pour aller chercher tadornes
voudraient s'y donner des pays qu un
jour donné ils ont donné un joint ou
âgées radio se lance depuis tantôt merci
je pose mon beau jeu de paume monde et
faire savoir comment changer s'est
déchaussé des joueurs qui règle aucun
problème à phoenix absolument et luigi
qui demandent est-ce qu'on peut retirer
les suns de la nba alors alors dit je
veux dire je te dire législativement je
ne sais pas c'est pas grave ça dépend si
leurs finances sont saines ils ont
peut-être une place en pro b et ses
limites avec eux donc
voilà la commission financière on sait
pas il ya des signataires d'une pétition
qu en train de se monter donc donc
pourquoi pas et portland qui donne de
cloques manu tu sélectionnes qui cite et
portland là un joueur de basket il ya
qu'elle donne johnson encore qu'est la
wii jeunes gens encore là et me donne
johnson à portland pas des conneries
gamme htc lilian qui nous proposait ça
que je fais comme un poste 4
j'aimerais bien plus de 4 à portland
mais c'était pour remplacer offert
backup de dale farm gaming ouais mais
bon mon vieil homme c'était bien mais
bon il ya plus est ce qu est ce qui a
grandement donc pas là mais après il
reste dès lors il reste des joueurs
peut-être un petit peu plus en plus et
pas forcément j'aurais klaxons ni klaxon
lui fait jouer 4 je le fais jouer je me
fais juste défendre je demanderai rien
d'autre je défends juste tu fais tu
bloques et les dégâts les suns donne
choix deux premiers de premier tour en
2000 le choix des boks en 2020 et
pourtant quelques bons en 2020 ça va les
suppôts leur choix des bugs en 2020 ça
veut dire un jour à 25,30 voit enfin sa
équitable oui ça va être un truc c'est
possible on rappelle 2020 antoine
projeter ses bonnes grâces de des
arrières assez bonne pâte mais vous êtes
très dur avec cette journée on n'est pas
très dur avec ty dillon mais qui et quel
est son obsession est ce qu'ils seront
meilleurs un jour qu'en finale deux ans
y est bah non mais me il a été excellent
enfin je vois bien en rotation joueur de
rotation pendant une bonne
un bon 8 10 ans il fera plusieurs
contrats je pense à aulas laquelle
seigneur alors ben signes ostentatoires
steam
la first imca menzah le rosé avec classe
il a énormément de classe de la part des
rois qui vient de nous amener un là un
ravitaillement bienvenue je vous avoue
4h17 on n'a pas encore fini le premier
tour c'est long c'est très long sur
cette année non l'abc pays ces dix
minutes entre chaque pic ou quoi parce
que le salon qu'amazon ils sont plus un
doc clock les blazers c'est fini le
candidat je comprends pas ce manque lra
vas-y ben non ça me prenait part à 40
minutes je pense que la dernière longue
fera toujours
ouais hein ouais en tout cas nous on est
encore dans le studio je sais pas quand
est ce qu'on va se faire virer par le
veilleur de nuit mais j'essaie de rester
le plus longtemps possible
moi j'attends de voir ce que va faire
golden state t'attendant qui ont
l'habitude on a chuté des pics fin un
pic qui draft c'est généralement pas
trop mal et comme si une draft où les
gens en décembre décembre décembre ils
ont cédé sans moyens c'est une horreur
j'essaie de mettre à jour tous les
traits de la sur le site
je sais que je suis un peu perdu les
copains ouais c'est antoine tranquille
surtout que j'ai non mais c'est sûr que
j'ai plus de batterie sur mon ordinateur
portable et du coucher sur le téléphone
est tout vous savez tous à voilà enfin
il est la nôtre chauffe le divin chauve
c'est moi et portland qui sélectionne
nasir little but pied la loose faking
pic good way une situation idéale pour
lui qui vont qui va voir il va avoir
une utilité immédiate avec son
athlétisme sa défense park lane et tombe
dans une équipe qui est qu'un jeu quand
même assez sophistiqué et intellectuelle
libre et quand il va il va pouvoir
apprendre il va pouvoir prendre son
temps pas trop de pression
moi moi je me couvre pas rejoint par ses
3 4 ils vont pouvoir garder poste 2 3 4
moi j'aime beaucoup en pensant valable
et englobe une bonne en plus d'avoir
d'avoir envoyé un choix de premier tour
je sais pas si c'est à boston phoenix
phoenix est fertile et r'n'b bon à la
limite un petit peu de dureté pour aaron
baines à phoenix alors lembeye harold
baines par un phénix en même temps que
quand je pense que tout est lié
ouais ouais bon un peu de fierté c'est
pas mal je sais pas vous mais moi ça me
fait moins rire que taille de géant non
mais vous êtes hyper dur je pense qu'il
va vous faire bouffer vous j'aimerais
bien votre string en ont mais moi je
voulais le voir en euroligue déjà mais
c'est vrai et alors après sur le chat ça
plaît beaucoup ce choix de nassir little
com com pour vous antoine et ben manu tu
étais d'accord avec le consensus
ouais puis c'est un joueur qui va du
coup avec l'île heard et mc collum il va
pas avoir trop de pression sur lui il va
pouvoir exister et travailler dans le
calme tout en ayant un petit rôle
donc je pense que c'est très très bien
il va être un joueur de mission en
probablement dès l'année prochaine ben
tu disais lui demander de défendre et
puis et puis de bien shooté puis
peut-être de travail et de commencer à
travailler sa création quoi absolument
on lui demandait justement d'avoir des
stops on va lui demander de jouer de
jouer dur d'être agressif de le garder
le tempo mais on lui demandera pas de
d'être sauveur parce que le savoir
appréhender s'appelle des miels et le
donc oui moi je pense est idéal pour
l'huile les sages lui faire mal de
tomber comme ça mais
il est tombé comme sort pour une raison
qui est tombée comme une sorte comme ça
surtout dans la bonne position
absolument parce qu' il serait il serait
tombé au pic 11
imaginons groupe 9 genre pour lui ouais
cool parce que parce que genre pour ati
mora et captain run johnson on aurait
dit c'est n'importe quoi ce pic c'est de
la merde
le joueur est merdique mais ba ba pour
le coup ça marche parce qu'il est il est
pris au bon endroit comme ça ressemble à
la bonne situation ben oui non c'est
clair c'est tout ça c'est arrivé pour le
pour l'oeil pour le bénéfice de nez sur
lesquels il va et je crois qu'il va
évoluer puis va devenir un jour donné le
style de se demander pourquoi dacia est
tombé à 25 dans cinq ans et en voiture
va parce qu'il ya plein d'équipés qui
ont fait des conneries c'est sur ces
cinq là alors là à temps je suis
j'essaie de suivre qui est-ce qui
piquent au 26 et qu'ils veulent c'est
cleveland a hissé la cleveland
waouh seeland manuel lui se fait ce pôle
est mauvaise nous avec antoine on va
réagir comme ça ça fait sociaux les gens
viennent ils sont en train de parler des
chaussures de la madame donc l'assaut
perdu à nice aussi le sien et et voilà
26 cleveland
alors pourquoi voir où on sait pas c'est
le carreau c'est un choix très bien très
trèbes et line très très bon sens le
michif toute heure sur le post de 500me
schigand bah écoute mais après ils ont
déjà adapté darus garlande oui on en
avait pas parlé de ça car l'un de ces
petits pics et le jour le double bonheur
c'est typique de jungle c'est vrai la
traction arrière et il l'a toujours fait
sourire c'est rageant en tout cas ses
meilleures équipes ont toujours été
construite autour de deux meneurs quand
c'est vrai c'est vrai ils ont
complètement raison et on vous le
rappelle si vous de l'image vous mettez
vous et et bim et vous regardez romain
qu'aime le le suc a le plus d'alluré
d'entre nous bah oui c'est plus beau
voilà donc ben tu regardes roman pas
mairie la cabine
non non non je ne sais pas où le
regarder en fait je serais bien regarder
ça je pense une belle bouille on se dit
pas mais sur un deux trois tv.fr cm1236
vinao point com
mais tu enlèves le nord le 3 pv point fr
1 2 3 tv.fr oui mais je vois ça donne
des adresses
on est en fin de premier tour 4h24 nous
faut s'abonner 24 heures/24 et vous êtes
encore presque 100 à nous écouter en
direct ce qui vous êtes quand même fou
complètement fou mais on vous aime
j'espère que vous avez du rose et vous
aussi j'espère que vous avez du bon rosé
ou du bon saucisson mais ça me manque
ça nous manque on a fait un bon resto
ben
[Rires]
saloperie les cavs qui sont censé
choisir mais en fait j'ai l'impression
que le chrono ne sert à rien il le
laisse tourner cinq minutes et adam
silver arrive deux ans il voit minutes
après quoi un petit peu quand il veut
donc c'est un petit peu inquiet du rosé
je crois que ce rosé là bas aussi
compliqué chaouen mais moi j'en ai marre
de voir la gueule de jay chasse alors
brooklyn qui piquent en 27 le deuil à
aux clippers enfin le donnent les
chances aux clippers aux couettes adrián
rien ne dit pas adrien vosges champions
adam qui vient de choisir de cleveland
qui compte en amont non sérieusement
mais là on est sur du très très haut
niveau
dylan wind l'heure encore une fois les
shooteurs sont sur drafté dans sept ans
cette cuvée 2010 9 dylan leur qui est un
bon shooteur à l'automne oui bon
shooteur extraordinaire rebondeur pour
cette taille poste de 3 kg 3,4 à belmont
mais ni bordel fait je peux pas
m'empêcher de penser qu'à des comment
ils font les invitations dans la green
room c'est qu' il on voit des sondages
aux équipes quels sont vos tops machin
et il invite en fait ils font des
moyennes et les joueurs qui sont classés
dans le top 14 en général dans la
loterie quoi donc tu as des équipes
qu'on sciemment menti à la nba sciemment
pour inviter des nids claxton et des
émissions de kabengele way pour tromper
les autres et que les mecs sont en train
de pleurer toutes les larmes de leur
corps le faut penser un peu alors
apparemment 10 la wonder qui est costaud
au golf on voit sur les films hd spn un
très bon swing manu toi qui est un peu
spécial
pourquoi pas et oui non winder que ce
tandis que man u bah ouais shooter quoi
mais enfin je vois pas trop le jeu
comprend pas trop ce que fait qu'ils
vendent vieux athlétisme défense /
arrière création voilà les défauts de
dylan l'heure que vous pouvez voir en
direct
après c'est un joueur qui a pas besoin
du bassin les vicois c'est mike dunn
lily c'est mike dunn lévis en wave
j'aime bien la comparaison maiden navy
ouais mais on peux m'engager sur ses
pieds attachés
c'est un facteur de ses pieds 10 c'est
quoi c'est un facteur mais c'est un très
beau jeu c'est un très bon joueur
universitaire c'est un score assez un
bon rebondeur comme d'antoine mais
métier j'aurai pas de le dire à chaque
quelques podcasts la nba et
évolutionnaire au moment athlétiquement
les 60 meilleurs prospects sur 4000 à
chaque année il y aura un port
atlantique a franchi et qui comme rien
du tout et des lan wan là ne le franchir
pas un héros distille au deuxième tour
là ça va être dégueulasse
ouais et des länder cc il ne franchira
pas les aspects de la barrière en pleine
gueule surtout on est sur le sentier
quoi il va y avoir des styles comme
d'habitude plus que d'habitude peut-être
plus que d'habitude après selon nous je
ne trouve pas mes mais dylan wind
l'heure où il va il va avoir du mal à à
péter le plafond de la de la nba
ben tu me disait antoine moueix non mais
on le sait il est bien il sait faire
plein de choses mais on c'est pareil on
le voyait tous autour du pic 40 centres
40 45 à quelque chose comme ça le
prendre aussi aux basses et c'est se
priver d'une d'une flexibilité
financière aussi comme c'est vrai et
c'est se priver de deux choix fin j'ai
abandonné si tu veux ce jour-là trade en
quoi toutes les autres équipes nba
semblent vouloir très aidée tout cas un
moment donné bas fait le très très des
descendants de finalement qaïda la
nouvelle orléans filmon fini nouvelles
heures les oies nuland a dit voyez
quelques traits d'un homme mais assez
peu de futur futur à cette future pique
sur les années prochaines on aurait pu
peut-être penser que avec des trade and
les équipes peuvent voulait miser sur la
drague 2020 2021
idéalement 2022 s'appelait le cas par
des petits deuxième tour de 2020 par ci
par là un vrai beaucoup de traits de
courir beaucoup de traite qui sentent le
perdant perdant ben comme tu les aimes
au band équipes qui n'ont pas fait leur
devoir qui savent pourquoi pas au fond
on sait toujours pas qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que broken arrow sur brooklyn
l équipage vous voyez on est un choix de
premier tour en 2020 et leur 56e paix
que ce soit pour le pet numéro 20
premiers tours en 2020 ouais ouais
alors ok je vais ajouter ce trade
si les clippers crû de pâques hawaï ça
peut être une bonne chose un premier
tour 2020 pour brooklyn
bah oui mais c'est pas nécessairement
une très bonne chance
il ya d'excellents joie à qui ont glissé
la balle et c'est vrai que brooklyn ont
un public un bon joueur en back up à
jared allen
je pense que moqueries mais ils ont
surtout pas réussi à voir les joueurs
qui voulaient où ils ont déjà été pris
sondhi godeuil on prend on prend un truc
plus tard quoi c c'est possible donc
c'est des clippers qui récupère ans
c'est ça oui c'est possible brooklyn
j'ai l'impression qu'ils misent surtout
sur la free agency quoi ils ont vendu
leurs deux pics au final je gagne en
orient le 31e qui allait aussi mais oui
j'ai pas l'impression que j'ai
l'impression que c'est tout maintenant
et ça se passe à la truie agency pour
eux ici ici frappe
s'il frappe dans le bas
dans le beurre il n'y a pas grand chose
qui va arriver à l'année prochaine
ouais ouais c'est clair après voilà ils
doivent être plutôt confiant sur leur
sur l'histoire de kairi erving et
peut-être même de quelqu'un d'autre
s'ils font tousser move entrait il faut
espérer pour eux donc c'est les clippers
qui choisissent la sémec linky à l'écran
ça hyper ce qu'ils choisissent mais les
fans il est sympa ça c'est éthique non
mais bol on est rendu à 28 erwan tu es
déçu bolt qui est pas tout jeune à erwan
qui qui qui fait le service laquelle
seigneur écoute attention là c'est les
clippers qui choisit sa place ds
si on dit kabengela bing et les lave le
chouchou de la rédaction vous êtes erwan
qui nous dit on regarde à la télé là bas
à côté merci beaucoup et ouest pour le
studio le service le neveu dikembe
mutombo qui tombe dans ben qu'est ce que
tu penses de fioul ou aux clippers
je crois que c'est un excellent film
avec l'équipe du cabinet j'adore ce
choix il est il si un joueur énergique
qui est un joueur qui joue vraiment avec
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il ya non
répliquent des warriors non je ne leur
ai dit oui devant jaunard offs qui
équipent spoil un petit peu
vas-y vas-y continue sa longue et les
joueurs rennais au big up tempo qui va
qui va qui va bien jouer aux côtés des
montres choisi russell williams des
tchèques brûler ses restes à la censure
hein si ça arrive avec son shooting va
être capable de leur donner beaucoup de
flexibilité j'adore j'adore le site ses
chiens ses joueurs qui avaient dû sortir
beaucoup plus tôt et que les lakers vont
on a eu beaucoup de chance d'aller
chercher bon tu aime beaucoup
si on dit qu'est ce que tu en penses toi
manu je suis en train de regarder un
petit peu la situation financière et du
roasters des clippers qu'on n'a pas trop
analyser je sais même pas si je peux en
fait je n'avais pas de pic manu qu'est
ce tu penses de kabengele j'aime
beaucoup plus jeunes beaucoup le
shooting le rebond l'activité le
footwork moi j'aime j'aime beaucoup
c'est étonnant qu'ils tombent si bas et
je pense que là les clippers fois un
joli coup ouais
d'autant qu'ils aient je sais pas ce
qu'ils ont fait ou batch il a encore à
moins que sont team option nouveaux
restricted je sais pas ce match suivant
contre son poids en or des gagnants il
pèse dans le game qui pèse sur le 12 mai
et est ainsi est un gars comme fuel où
on peut faire jouer on peut faire jouer
en 4-5-1 jusque quand je faisais la
comparaison avec halloween callejón
jukka t5 et je mens cesse et c'est sur
nrj play offs et un doc sur un vieux con
mais pour changer le tempo d'une partie
et jack reçoit l'as d'or et je
l'apprécié
j'aime bien cette comparaison il peut
jouer avec monde 13 l arène
bah oui absolument ils vont s'adorer les
deux là ils vont crier tous les esprits
au visage le père faure ah oui bon il
pense qu'ils envisagent ils vont faire
pour aller 2000
je suis désolé j'ai pas actualiser le
pic 27 je fais plein de choses en même
temps excusez moi sur le tchat
ça vient dans quelques secondes sur vos
écrans m fund ou kabengele le centre de
florida state university costaud long
dur sur l'homme
contrairement un peu de shoot exter un
peu de shoot exter voilà une belle
mentalité
dans l'ensemble on l'a vu formalisez pas
il était sixième homme il était meilleur
que tous les titulaires et j'ai jamais
entendu râler dire monsieur dave être
titulaire et c'est alors il ya des
choses qu'on s'est adressé non mais mais
il a accepté ce rôle il acceptera
probablement le rôle que un peu baissé
la télé ouais j'ai essayé il acceptera
certainement le rôle que lui donnera doc
rivers derrien luigi viande ou kabengele
par contre manu c'est pas un joueur qui
fait des passants sinon ça trop c'est un
joueur qui joue près du cercle
essentiellement aussi veut s'écarter il
peut s'écarter mais c'est moi j'aime
beaucoup son activité près du progrès du
cirque plus que plus que sont hier même
si son tir est intéressant après il me
semble qu'il n'est pas très très jeune
il n'est pas jeune ans
le profil qu'elle h 22 il va avoir 22
novembre il aura 22 ans écoute il ait
pas plusieurs idiomes drenthe heures
et on sait à peu près ce qu'on achète
ben quand on achète thank you do kabange
oui on achète un on a chanté un pivot
qui met des écrins qui qu'il roulait au
cercle en échec qui finit dépossession
qui défend qui est très long quoique il
ya sept 7 pieds 4 2 d'envergure donc il
ya beaucoup beaucoup aimé ces joueurs là
je me serais attendu ce soir à 18
personnes
non j'ai cru qu'on ne perde est vrai
tout va bien ouais je vois bien ouais
ouais tout va bien tu y restes en août
au board
ben en ce moment hoarau d'amont board je
veux te dire ça exactement le plus haut
qui reste mal blue qui reste pour
l'instant ces beaux albums que j'avais
noms qui viennent pointer un parking
pour te joniaux enfin l'ancien nom tel
en tant que est toujours lié toujours
toi et moi aussi ça la culture mont
board avec kevin porter effectivement
même si il était bien descendu à cause
de ses problèmes probablement un peu
dans dans la tête
ball bol quand même aussi je vais quand
même relativement haut et après presse a
dans l'ensemble été pris
peut-être un après j brasse des kiss moi
directement bref ce que je vais à près
de 58 chf kpodji manu tu as qui dans ton
bordj sais pas si tu l'avais actualise
est à même d'améliorer miliana bio ni je
l'avais début de second mois au premier
tour j'avais
et le alors qu'elle donne johnson kevin
porter claxton tiéti fernando bol inouï
king daniel gars ford et voilà ouais bon
écoutez warriors wars il leur faudra
rayon ses surprises encore j'ai vu il
leur faut du shoot on ne sait pas il ya
des pubs tous les deux piles ajavon 100
votants il à contretemps manu dans le
futur je suis dans le futur il est dans
le turf eus avec mes bébés mais par
contre va pas falloir qu'ils nous
habitue trouve à faire des ddd des
séquences comme cette draft avec des
pubs à gogo c'est un peu chiant ouais
c'est un peu moins bien que les autres
années j'ai l'impression ouais un peu
moins rythmée bah oui parce que il ya
vraiment après c'était peut-être parce
qu'ils aient beaucoup d'attentes sur
l'âge chez pas sûr beaucoup de suspense
du coup ils en profitent font du blé
je sais rien s'ils se font de l'audience
je t'aide qu'ils étaient tous seuls à
avoir un gros événement soir aux
etats-unis j'en sais rien mais grosso
merdo oui d'habitude ça commence à 2h30
et ça on y à peu près au même point
qu'en ce temps-là ouais ça oui c'est
vrai là on n'a pas fini le premier tour
avant 6h du matin il reste 2 peak 2 peak
ça va trois pics 28 29
d'habitude le 28 et apte et du coup mais
golden state and the clock du coup je
crois ça dp cuisine
les warriors qui secoue une situation
assez particulière et c'est adam silver
le dow jones et des warriors
le 28ème choix de cette draft 2010 9 et
les warriors ont choisi jordan foule
ok j'ai même mais lui s'attendait pas
quoi soit guy poule qui est content du
coup un ba oui il peut il peut être
content c'est la meilleure équipe des
warriors
moi je l'avais plus tôt enfin pour moi
ça un rôle clair capable il est capable
il peut donc il est au coeur et hachez
les lunettes les ressemble à rien dit il
qu'il y en a eu lieu dans les systèmes
de john b line donc c'était un poste 2
qui était capable de porter le ballon
ouais parce que voilà il jouait du
belling joue toujours avec deux arrières
distributeurs et je sais que sur les
work outs jordan poule à shooter comme
un comme un dieu vivant
et vu les finales nba
évidemment ils sont dix golden state on
aimerait bien avoir des shooteurs
complémentaire très ça tu disais besoin
de shooting c'est pas très étonnant manu
un seul choix de ce choix de jordan
poule ouaip in notamment su par rapport
à 1,1 queen cook a vraiment d'issue ou
shooting dans la finale donc bon après
c'est pas forcément un mineur mais pas
pour non non il va il va pas il sait pas
non plus un créateur ouais ouais ouais
c'est pas un mec qui va forcément créer
sur le pick and roll pour l'instant il
n'a pas montré sa qu'est ce que tu
penses de quand tu me projette en
défense ben nott non mais on parle de
ses sourcils soir quand ses sourcils
sourcils épilés je sais pas mais non
justement
vraiment dommage qu'un peu on a en effet
répondre mais le raymond domenech de
michigan
[Rires]
[Musique]
comment je le trouve bien défensivement
jordan poule avant que tu me donnes ton
avis sur le fit avec les warriors
je ne sais pas je sais pas dans les
schémas défensifs des variances comment
le projet commun qui qui garde dans une
série finale quand on rentre au fred van
fleet
ce qui est assez physique pour garder ce
qui est assez physique
regardez qu'est ce qui est fait à pied
d'explosifs contre un kyle lowry
je ne sais pas oui c'est un bon shooteur
mais il m'a l'air d'un gars des malades
en work as voyages dans la plus pure des
traditions je suis pas convaincu du tout
de ce type pour gold peut-être mais
vraiment pas pas convaincus de ce pic
le canadien bon moi j'aime bien jordan
poule
ouais trouve que c'est un bon shooteur
en plus il a si la montre et enfin c'est
même un très bon shooteur il avait pas
les choux de très ouvert un michigan
c'est un système un peu resserré
offensivement ce n'était pas ce n'est
pas le michigan d'il ya quelques années
où c'était tout feu tout flamme avec les
traits burke mixte au ska et compagnie
donc quand on vient à regretter très
peur c'est qu'on est un peu dans la
merde car évidemment
en régularité c'est marqué dans ses
défauts antoine tu l'as trouvé un peu
bendaoud cette année ah bah oui oui
surtout surtout au niveau du shoot comme
oh mon dieu les sourds si tu vois ses
sourcils c'est quand même quelque chose
et c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on a noté
régularité d'ailleurs la régulière des
sourcils c'est important aussi
non c'est oui sur laquelle était
régulier non mais oui il a fait des
sorties 30 change de propriétaire à base
y parle des traits d'alors du coup il
appartenait à milwaukee qui l'envoya
détroit et détroit l'envoie à cleveland
hommes et où des 3 l'envoi clive alors
qu'il en dit long prix qui en 26 qu'ils
vendent ils ont pris 10 lundi la loisne
l'heure il fallait y vont une autre
pique
ils veulent nous surprendre donc ils
veulent un pic à temps vient on fait des
paris j'ai détesté des joueurs sombre de
n 6 de belley la présence des six mois
je vois pourquoi avec chris cléments
c'est le meneur qui joue pour quelles
facs je connais même pas le nom de la
fac bas clemson nancy non non c'est pas
classe et campbell campbell la fac de
caen b donc c'est une grosse le major et
qui était le meilleur scoreur pied l'an
dernier sauf qui ferra mètre soixante
dix et qui fait que ce qu'aurélie qaeda
on voit encore 4 second tour pour le 30
4 second tour
quant au fils qui pète un plomb on adam
silver san antonio qui choisit qu'elle
donne johnson des gens qu'on les
condamne changent de veste
tant que l'homme au oui monsieur c'est
oui il enlever il enlever les rideaux de
mamie il est en blanc
et là il a gagné la drave ce soir aulas
oui
aulas oui à un joueur qui a plusieurs
équipes au dessus qui pourront penser
que ça pulse et khémisset mois plusieurs
équipes au de ceux qui vont se mordre
les doigts ben tu penses ans à ba oui
moi je l'aimé j'ai toujours aimé qu'elle
donne j'entends un joueur un peu dans le
moule de gains au sol humant accepter
qu'ils jouent peut-être que 3-4 que le 3
il est plus utile et très petit pour sa
position oui c'est un défenseur
absolument acharné il est bien performé
au shoot cette saison donc on peut rire
de tout même si pas 100% convaincu mais
mais je crois qu'il va donner une bonne
dose d'énergie aux spurs temps quitte t
on va avoir besoin d'un décrochage manu
ouais moi c'est un beau c'est un joueur
sans style 1 c'est un joueur qui était
sur le papier en tout cas c'est un
joueur qui était attendu beaucoup plus
au kaki qui solide sur le catch and
shoot plutôt correct en défense moi je
ne trouve que ça va mais on voit les
images mais ce qui est intéressant chez
qu'elle donne jeunes seuls c'est la
taille du chien sydney 'solides'
américain sait pas comment traduire ça
en français mais la capacité de prendre
des décisions fortes c'est à dire j'ai
le ballon je fais un truc immédiatement
et avec un haute intensité lorsque je
veux dire il est comme ça il défend
comme ça il sait je pense un défenseur
de résidents sur cette draft en haut
lieu on leur fait un gros défenseur
et en cas de chute en fait il était
prévu très haut dans les draft dauphin
les les scouts c'est tout le monde
l'aimait beaucoup avant et le mettait
dans son top 10 et parce qu'ici pas à se
créer son propre shoot on s'est dit bon
en fait non il est nul bah non il est
pas nul et un matisse 'table seimat
istanbul avec 80 k way mois en mois
votre mot des outils mois
mon développer comme forme il avoué oui
mais je veux dire il n'a pas les outils
physique je parle mehdi enfin saint pour
moi c'est au moins de quoi enfin juste
c'est sert à rien de faire des rites
surfaite côté les spurs eux les celtics
étaient juste attendre que les héritiers
les autres fassent des offres
9 ça m'a dit je l'avais en vain teckel
qu'à l'époque les six heures le vouloir
en 24 ouais nous tout ce qu'on a dit de
mal sur sa manici là un peu effacé lors
du nba combined donc qu'il y avait plus
grand-chose à dire de mal c'était au
t'étais pas là au moment du pic antoine
mais c'est si on parle de la draft des
spurs en général c'est pas si
dégueulasse que sa manie de bois n'ont
carrément pas c'est magnifique et dan
johnson on vous lit je regarde je
regarde ce qui se passe sur le sur le
chat qui est assez ou très du nombre de
joueurs de la green room qui restent et
que horton tankers reste aussi que kevin
porter du junior reste c'est so lu ment
c'est vrai que nous aussi on est surpris
1 vous n'êtes pas les seuls
après on pouvait s'attendre un peu à
tous après le pic 4 on n'a pas été déçu
manière on s'attend terrine drafté
youlou elle est là c'est sa foule yolo
c'est pas forcément étonnant qu'on suit
une trappe rempli de role players donc
les jeux les jouets enfin sur un peu du
n'importe quoi je suis non non non tu es
toi mais du n'importe quoi c'est du
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi c'est du
n'importe quoi et donc là le 30 tu nous
dis que c'est les cavs qui vont drafté
avec ce 30 contre 4 second tour donc
fois on l'avalé crois qu'ils doivent pas
si mal du coup attend shineski drafted
raf ses coûts et du tout et il récupère
quatre second tour pouvoir les années du
coude avec 36%
ils ont viré
le meilleur ils ont récupéré tony chenal
c'est plutôt correct
donc au final aussi ses limites
play-offs à l'est occupé retenir schnell
via deux ans de contrat un peu
dégueulasse sur tony schnell mais
pourquoi pas mais pour pour ça il
récupère quatre second tour de detroit
ont inscrit
philadelphie envoie johnattan siemens et
le 42 au wild en retour selon selon cham
de la flexibilité sur le cap salarial je
sais pas trop ce qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
il se débarrasse de johnatan en gros
attentats
on leur fait jonathan simons et les 42 6
miles 42 quai envoyé acquis déjà à
washington à washington contre ce qu'ils
étaient outrés brooklyn et ses raids
puis c'est les mêmes avec bane barils
oui c'est même rouquet maintenant ils
exhibaient brooklyn et c'est donc là ne
ferrait d'échangés présent mal de
confiance
donc ils tuent et parle de lâche
complètement à oued qui valide les caps
quoi ils veulent deux contrats max j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont un peu le seul
ils ont vraiment pas eu des gens qui
voulaient où il vit 526 millions et du
fondre à personne c'est possible au
second tour et alliances au second tour
aucune publication n'était pas obligé de
le signer tu peux signer après sur des
des minimums joue pas je commençais à
poser la question tout à l'heure celle
de luigi dans le chat qui demande une
explication qu'on parlait on disait yolo
draft etc
ils demandent quand même les mecs c'est
des pros etc on dit c'est vrai que nous
on est surpris par tel ou tel choix ben
comme comment cela peut s'expliquer dans
lé front office c'est simplement une
évaluation différente que celle que nous
on a fait en fait ben ouais mais ce que
je peux expliquer c'est que lorsque les
enjeux sont bas lorsqu'on discute drafté
est faible c'est que léger léger les
thèmes et les professeurs pêche chadha
avec leur coeur plus qu'avec leurs tests
dès que je vois qu'il aime il se pose
pas de questions ils vont le chercher
parce que ça va être pour rob ablement
un rôle clair de toute façon à part
peut-être pour les trois quatre premiers
si on inclut le chart cover qui je crois
au potentiel itunes store on n'a pas de
d'énormes potentiels en scène rare si
donc thème cameron johnson à 11 soit
chercher comment johnson arrosé tu pose
pas la question je crois que c'est un
choix avec plus de valeur mais c'est ce
qu'on veut dire par you look un
quincaillier très peu d'enjeu bain et
tout le monde le plein tout est d'être
un peu n'importe quoi et c'est un peu ce
qui se passe ce soir et ça va être très
rigolo de jouer au jeu auquel on a joué
en plateau avec les casquettes pour
cette draft là parce qu'il y aura des
joueurs avec des casques est
complètement improbables ou même pôle le
volant alors qu'est ce qu'un rapport à
l'équipe dans laquelle ils ont atterri
au final c'est un peu ridicule
d'ailleurs et devrait mettre ouais mais
les tarifs seront officielles que plus
grand une casquette c'est pas très
officiel quoi enfin il ya le logo
derrière et c'est enfin bref
donc là c'est les bucks qui vont choisir
qui l'avait envoyé à détroit qu'il
envoyait ensuite à cleveland à cleveland
à fo sur rfo suivre au succès de la
gymnastique intellectuelle à 4h53 du
matin au quai le car on est deux à frais
le 42 ça sera pour washington
contrairement aux roses etc et freiner
un peu vide ça comme ça aux jets
wasserman nous écoute là bas et voir
antoine etrait ski sur ton bord de jeu
d'intéressant la claque du texte les
plus hauts sur tombeur de l'as dans ta
tête board mental ouais et je m'embête
une caméra survole grand bol attention
et adam silver les cases
kevin porter du junior oyez dégoûte
il est belge il a fait la grimace mais
son contrat garanti après j'aime
beaucoup la couleur du costume est ce
que j veux ni le savait mais j veu n'y
avait ni kevin porter 30 ha ouais ouais
ouais mais ça avec tous les élèves cette
draft il fallait l'annoncer salue
l'annoncé surtout qu'il avait annoncée
du coup après le trait de détroit oui
mais à cleveland
donc sachant qu il faut le rappeler
qu'une porter c'est un poste 2 qui a
besoin du ballon pour s'exprimer et
qu'avec que l'hymne sexton et d'un bus
cars allende et dylan wing l'heure ça va
devenir un challenger aux [ __ ] ses
chaussures wafa dylan moon lors ses
chaussures la haye
mais il y en a beaucoup qui sont venus
avec la petite le pantalon retroussé
l'ain mais ça c'est les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui mais est-ce que c'est
comme ça au canada
est-ce qu'on voit le bas des mollets
est-ce qu'on voit les chevilles non mes
excuses nous de mode est ce que vous
portez des motifs jungle ou qu on
appelle cela le bas du pantalon et veste
on appelle ça avoir de l'eau sous sol
[ __ ] c'est une cata ah oui non c'est
dégueulasse et je sais pas pourquoi il
essaie de tout les porter mais non j'ai
pas vu j'ai pas porté attention aux
souliers de de kevin porter est ce
qu'ils sont puis au moins pires que ceux
de kelly aubry ya quelques années alors
ça c'est une bonne une bonne question de
connaisseurs manu il a montré une vraie
capacité reconnaître donc je pense
qu'ils s'y connaît beaucoup les jeux sur
john riggins moi [ __ ] mais c'est un
peu et même avec un petit îlot gohar
argenté c'etait tres été très regardée
avec cette petite veste au rouge je
regarde ce google
bon maintenant on va arriver au de
second tour
donc les avantages c'est que devraient
avoir moins de pub et que ça devrait
aller plus vite et que le temps est
limité raccourcie par rappela
normalement il ya deux minutes entre
chaque clic
du coup au second tour donc maintenant
c'est toutes les deux minutes et il nous
reste donc dans la green room la baule
bol ça me fait marrer quelque chose soit
non yann il ya claxton et bassins style
yabeun vol et qui d'autre
orton toker il allait amener de coeur
ouais était pas green home halal est
tenu de nom kevin porter on en a on n'a
pas trop débriefer mais qui est porteur
voilà on en a parlé un peu pendant
l'année c'est le mec qui a eu quand même
des problèmes psychologiques
wes pas ouais bah
c'est romain qui soulevait ça c'est
qu'il ya un match où il avait joué que 4
minutes et y avait rien eu autour n'y
avait pas eu de blessure d'annoncer rien
du tout donc est ce que c'était mais ils
étaient coupées il a complètement pété
un câble quand ça après ça reste un
joueur intéressant en folie moi j'aime
bien j'aime bien sa défense je trouve
qu'il a vraiment des dix outils
intéressants en défense il doit
travailler six prises d'écran par contre
parce que sur beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
et ici ce qui se colle aux poseurs
d'écran et puis il fait plus rien il
arrive il fait pas l'effort d'aller soit
de switcher soin de le passer même si
leurs tarifs il y va pas donc sage et
j'aime
après je trouve qu en attaque y beaucoup
pour rien ça et dream beaucoup et du
coup sahara sans empathie sur son défi
jeune viking
mais si tu les mets toi ben en attaque
je l'aimé je l'aimais par environ six
semaines
je la passion un amour volage benz pour
ça ben oui mais mais comment c'est venu
une bouée une bonne part parce qu'ils
étaient capables de créer son propre
chaude ils étaient explosées c'est les
mains des sens on omet qu'un premier pas
de feu mais mais il commençait un peu à
croire sa propre légende et à se trouver
vraiment très très très très brillant
est ici mis à dribbler ses billets et
s'est mis à la gauche à droite a refusé
de passer le ballon et là c'est devenu à
créer des gros problèmes pour lui aussi
et il commençait à jouer de moins en
moins passade à ce moment là et il amène
sa joie mais on se retrouve à cleveland
avec jr smith et vous savez le le mime
internet avec les deux spider man qui se
pointe l'un et l'autre ne s'était pas vu
son costume je comprends je comprends
pas non plus le costume
deux noms sont payés dans les grands
j'ai dit de l'histoire de la barre c'est
complet absolument je crois que c'est un
des jeux où je joue franchement c'est un
des pires les yeux eliakim nova je pense
joakim noah pardon oui c'était bien mais
c'était bien moche bah on a vu que
stephen curry s'était absolument affreux
ouais non mais là avec l'espèce de
toiles d'araignées c'est quand même pour
moi c c c c top 1
il sera peut-être il y sera au second
tour ball bol mais enfin le on espère
pour lui parce que c'est quand même
dramatique mais très mauvais si je suis
l'équipe kildare
je lui faire enlever son complet le
deuxième tour ça va aller plus vite
normalement messieurs dames on va on va
pouvoir
ben je mange et on espère qu'ils aient
spin le pass way normalement c'est
toutes les deux minutes là ils sont
peintes de clopes en trois heures et
normalement ils vont arrêter l'image des
pubs toutes les cinq minutes ils vont on
peut avoir à la pâte
remercie on peut remercier quand même
rémy et binck ont fini leur live la roma
a pu aller se coucher on les remercie
pour romain on les remercie pour romain
pour qu'il puisse l on la remercie de
nous avoir fait confiance du roman sans
compter mme romain tu étais très beau
c'est vrai beaucoup d'alluré
j'ai regardé la reprise demain avec le
t-shirt envergure
évidemment oui il y en avait qu'un seul
qu'il n'avait pas il y avait un t-shirt
draftexpress à ma gauche là ils sont un
petit peu du côté d'antoine quand même
il nous a vus ben ou pas à l'image
bah oui oui je vous ai vu mais là moi je
suis déçu de je m'étais coupé la barbe
bien comme il faut je me dis si tu es
déçu courtois d'envoyer la photo à paris
ouais ouais j'ai allégé leur donna écolo
sur le che non sans un petit avis sur le
chien de ben et on peut deviner son
prénom on va voir les vrais fans ceux
qui étaient là ils savent
oui ils savent le prénom du shin beth
qui gagna un tee shirt on en verrait
bien faire gagner un t-shirt envoie elle
est à côté de moi présentement dans l
d'or alors sagement cette kim est plus
beau que son maître tu te cela n'est bon
ça va pas c'est complètement faux et je
trouve ça vraiment pas cool par contre
chante mieux que son maître oui puisque
antoine et au canada cette saison
cette saison et je suis est scooté
montréal il a les scouts et du hockey et
effectivement
je pense que une draft id leben au
karaoke quoi oh oui c'est oui pour
sylvain laffont mais bon je note le nom
sylvain laffont sylvain chez nous
contacter sur twitter français richard
thiele est pour toi et il y en a
beaucoup qui répondent scarlett la torah
c'est mort c'est fini c'est trop tard
les autres est dommage mais je sais ça
explose là bas est ce que ce serait pas
pour bolt ouais il adore ball bol 2,31
le 31 c gepa jeu paul fait le pressing
son nom c'est brooklyn au brooklyn mais
attends ils vont faire un seul pays qui
vont prendre balle molle mais t'as pas
dit qu'il le trait des scpi klein il
essayait de crédit ayant probablement
pas été capable ok bon et ma faim si tu
veux tu arrives pas le trait d pas ok ok
bold c'est ok mais je pense quand même
encore mieux à faire ah oui
ah bah oui bah là il reste claxton on le
voit l'image d'ailleurs mairie spn
burgos d'ailleurs ni claxton beau gosse
et toujours souriant toujours souriant
alors c'est bon alors que bolt bol de
deux enfants mais ni claxton vraiment
beaucoup de swag on aime bien costard
blanc chemise noire ne pas prugger
chiffres rouges
aucune faute de goût rouge bordeaux non
mais il sait en quelques semaines j'aime
bien c'est vraiment un gamin qui a la
tête sur les épaules oui absolument
ça rigole dans l'équipe first team à mon
avis à mon avis ça régale
est ce vrai qu'on a du coup on à eric du
eric pascal héry vrai call que toi tu
aimes bien bons rôles players n'a dû le
guen ce porte qui claque un bac + 5 ans
mcdonald's et
pour vous raconter l'anecdote sur le
once d'or tu voi qui sera drafté on veut
la règle on vous la racontera wells il
est pas grave tu es là oui bah ils
vivent est gracile et pas drafté on la
raconte à la fin
ouais on attend on attend quand même on
veut pas le blâmer c'est bon pour vous
ce bond le guen ce qui est quand même de
ta ville ben ce temps comme boy
ouais c'est mais si tu disais un mec du
5e arrondissement de paris que avec de
servilité de sa ville toi j'ai
absolument oui souligné les montréalais
en nba mémorial nbim samuel dalembert
techniquement ils représentaient ahizi
en nba mais sa mort et il y en a déjà eu
un autre comme un temps mais ouais c'est
juste chaud juste un peu triste qu'ils
soient pas repêché en première ronde
parce que c'est vraiment ça a été le
premier québécois au premier tour depuis
samuel dalembert il est en même temps je
crois que porte là n'auraient plus à
être très intéressés à lui s'il n'y
avait pas eu la chaîne d'hôtels
disponibles à vannes 13e j'aurais été
cleveland j'aurais pris le guen ce dirt
devant kevin porter sans sourciller
défense plus d'énergie plus de soigner
plus de toulouse de villamée réaction
quand il parle en français pas fait que
je connais pas l'accent montréal-nord
même alors que ben quand on s'appelle le
vice-président là c'est eux qui va
annoncer les piques du second tour
alors lui je suis pas pourquoi je
n'aimes pas tu dire physiquement
non mais physiquement il ya roger
c'est je sais pas pourquoi mais toujours
en fait c'est toujours en train de
sourire de sourire comme comme un benêt
et j'aime pas c'est un peu la barre
sourires de faux-cul
c'est ça c'est exactement ça c'est
complètement fait qu et ça me saoule
mais sinon on fait bien le second tour
maintenant monsieur nba puisque brooklyn
a eu en 20 minutes pour choisir un c'est
insupportable
est-ce qu'on a des relents de noël que
roman a placé sur bin et ça c'est beau
apparemment et le bébé avec l'eau du
bain
gardant de noël sans il est magnifique
je suis protégé
j'ai pensé à la femme qu'elle était
qu'elle était d'acheter car thomas m'a
demandé mon opinion c'est vrai qu'on
aurait pu faire les classiques on attend
la draft d'admiral sco fil pour vous
raconter une anecdote qui ont une
nouvelle fois là celle-là il a requis la
marque et doute y avait cette coupe de
cheveux cette de cheveux quelle excuse
pas bienvenue au second tout madame mark
teitell aller s'te plaît à couches
les net's ni klaxon bon choix style
style
bah oui c'est dans le choix la tête les
timeline n'est pas forcément excellente
non ouais on y est c'est ce qu'ils
recherchent
il est meilleur que jared allen
populaire signale que c'est possible
c'est possible si ces jeux mais
franchement les tu peux avoir du
potentiel mais la question est comment
tu gagnes des minutes ce qui te
permettent de développer ce potentiel
csii claxton il va gagner des minutes en
défendant défense en défilant sans tut
tut tut tut verrou la raquette
tu call des contres et les restes bas on
verra dans
six mois dans un an dans deux ans tu lis
bien yacine dans les jambes et le mec ça
devient une star dans trois ans quand la
sinne yacine le coach personnel de phare
personnel de développement des joueurs
de limoges cette année khedri a posé
actuellement ses coûts et qui bosse avec
rudy actuellement absolument bisous un
bi zoua yacine sans doute coucher à
cette heure-là mais qui méritent des
bisous bâle bâle bâle bâle va gagner le
prix du dernier cas dans la green room
est le prix du cem du som qui était pour
l'instant détenu par
comment il s'appelle la charade luis non
non j'ai pu qui [ __ ] et qui c'est qui
avait glissé des yankees davis avait
glissé jusqu'en gens au pic 35 un truc
comme ça alors qu'ils étaient dans la
green room aller noël c'était vraiment
un cador jusqu'au bout de sueur sur le
pitre alors le pic 32 il était indiana
on se rappelle dans l'échangé avec
phoenix et il va me amel contre 3 second
tour je m'en occuperai demain puisque
les traits du second tour alors
qu'antoine y met à jour le site en même
temps rien que pour vos beaux yeux
donc tout ce qui est raide les équipes
qui piquent là ça va devenir un enfer le
second tour tu as toujours 200 milles à
enrico dans la jeune zaz de mao cameron
bat nuque est ce que tu en penses de
nick claxton honnête cela j'aime
beaucoup mais ouais j'aime beaucoup
parce que je trouve que c'est le je la
veux dans ma mob déjà alors j'avais déjà
les deux mc daniels pardon en 31 mais
non je trouve que c'est vraiment un
joueur qui qui leur manque un petit
claque comme ça capable de tout faire
pas du camp là sous la [ __ ] donc
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup à voir
sur le terrain
maintenant oui à des fiches pour le
second tour
mon ami sicko basse tu vois la fiche de
nicolas claxton qui est peut-être pas la
plus complète mais protection du cercle
polyvalence défensive qi basket c'est
pas un athlète de fufu ben may mais
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît aussi bon
passeur absolument bon passage quelques
équipements
c'est ce qu'on appelle un point de
ceinture de sega qui peut gérer le
français va partir du rôle de pivot et
moi j'aime beaucoup et je trouve que ce
genre de joueur ou cuit quand même axe
athlétique qui est capable de courir
qu'il y ait cadre exactement dans le
programme des nets et on remercie alexis
c'est lui qui camille que indiana avait
traité le numéro 30 de miami tu
confirmes ben ah oui c'est déjà l'heure
déjà l'heure du coup kesy okpala qui va
miami du coup quasiment pas l'ami m6
photo éric buron son rosé c'est ouf
et oui il est fini le rose et le sommeil
amène le lou capian manu manu basique
ezio pas là du coup à miami ouais ouais
rhmani non c'est un joueur cas qui doit
se développer en fait j'aime beaucoup il
attaque le cercle mais j'ai du mal avec
le l'ul son tir trouve qui là encore il
n'a pas montré qu'ils pouvaient tirer
qui savait tirer donc là dessus je suis
intransigeant sur le tir ouais faut
savoir bien les shooteurs toi ouais ben
toi tu les aimes bien pour moi qaïsi
ouais je l'avais deux sens entre
deuxième tour dans mes dernières modes
mais oui je pense celui d'entre nous
qu'il aime le plus j'ai trouvé qu'on
l'avait laissé un peu tout seul avec
avec la compagnie qui il faisait un peu
n'importe quoi mais c'est un joueur qui
chemin qui attaque qui quitteraient à 7
sec attaque le cercle qui affame capable
de défendre
je trouve qu à petit on pense d'une
situation qui est parfaite pour lui à
miami
parce qu'il va pouvoir prendre un rôle
qu'il a voulu donner des directives cela
il va s'adapter à cela je pense qu il va
fleurir comme un triumvirat nba tu vas
pas partial trendy et clairement là avec
lui tu parlais d'une comparer d'une
comparaison avec trevor ariza qui lui
aussi choix est mal à son arrivée aux
antillais et finalement qui avait
progressé tout comme d'opale à 22%
première année 37 2e année et ea les au
choix deux des buts 12e tôt c'est ça
donc on reste dans le ton reste dans la
comparaison
miami c'est pas mal pour développer les
joueurs clairement on est d'accord
absolument donc donc écoute plutôt un
bon choix de la part du 8 probablement à
en 32 notre but allait norton tucker est
toujours là ben on avait presque oublié
merci luigi oh la la il ya eia luc du
magic
j'ai vu ce qu'est venu l'autre fois dans
le temps le steyer dans le live et qui
dit on va prendre bol au magic on prend
les joueurs blessés ouais pourquoi pas à
jeter ses shootings la cud voilà c'est
possible c'est possible kaysing pas là
c'est un joueur qui qui sera prêt dans
combien d'années ben si tu devais faire
un pari la vingtaine d'anciens je pense
qu'il va atteindre son son son plafond
enfin qu il est quand même assez vite
puis c'est sur ce point je m y associer
et on va la mettre dans les coins et on
va recevoir des ballons pour shooter
detroit il va défendre dépasse pas les
lignes de passes et amiens dans un
programme qui est sain comme miami je
peux voir dans vraiment à devenir
wellington klaus lucien wayne ellington
plus plus pas mal lilian d'aidé
des bladers qui nous dit est ce que
comme d'eric jones miami art est arrivé
en faire quelque chose est-ce que palais
dans le même moule
moins athlétique quand même ouais ouais
moins critique que celle qui joue en
compagnie d'eric jones cède eric john
junior qui mon dieu oh mon dieu oui des
rides janvier capable de sauter par
dessus le base ball de mai puis bouillis
un peu moins long que des briques change
aussi mais qui est plus versatile
j'avais capable de faire plus de choses
parce que j'avais une chance j essaye d
essais de john key dans ta gueule c'est
un peu tout ça c'est pas un mais mais un
autre pas laïque a pas bien marc tatum
qu'arrive ben 33 ouais c'est bonduois
sixers août bordeaux à houston du coup
boston carson et de vars
c'est marrant avec le sait les sixers
qui le sélectionne je crois qu'ils n'ont
pas l'air au courant les fans tu
finalement il va aller à boston bah
écoute du shooting à boston ont besoin
ouais mais est ce que c'est vrai ici
esquivé il peut jouer maintenant à une
bille est belle pour toi car senghor ils
vont avoir à jouer à main d'oeuvre nba
non il va jouer maintenant
le chef de la cnec chez c'est aussi
simple que cela et si ici pas capable de
jouer meneur earpad minutes en billets
parce qu'ils reposent ces deux jeux vous
diront on répétera pas l'expérience du
meurtre est d'être là l'expérience je me
faisais tout le monde a appris de ça
plus personne ne veut pas ça ne veut
être les nouveaux personne doit être les
nouveaux bios qui hockey dont je le
vends un spoiler mais chez ce pas lui
qui m'a rendu très heureux père personne
personne doit être nouveau qui est
extrême
ça m'étonne pas du tout ouais un tel
choix parce qu pas qu'ils soient pas au
niveau de poste de way
carson edwards manu
il ya quand même des questions decision
making ouais mais c'est un gros gros
gros shooteur quoi moi je suis pas je
suis pas mécontent de ce choix je trouve
que ça peut le faire à la ja thomass a
réussi pourquoi ils réussiraient pas à
oui bah c'est pas le genre de joueur
les gars à l'apic 30 cadavres afin que
vous soyez sélectionné le 30 4 bat laon
tac ont été acquis à la base 6 ans et
les poses sexuelles ont changé quand
deux futurs et le 56 importe
oui mais donc le 57 atlanthal j'ai une
feuille devant moi elle veut plus rien
dire j'ai tout monté dessus avec un
feutre rouge
n'importe quoi le 34 va à atlanta très
bien atlanta qui a donc déjà drafté dit
andré hunter cam rédige et c'est tout
elise nom et y soit ou non la diva aux
pélicans so lu ment donc donc le 30 4 1
le 34 atlanta
bientôt hortons de coeur nous dit luigi
ça serait un très bonne pioche pour
atlanta mon avis atlanta vient de
prendre le pic 34 à philly contre futur
second round et 57
j'informe antoine de de la situation et
je vois que personne en dehors de cet
epic en 33 à boston ouais bah excellent
choix excellent excellent choix
à boston fait le nouveau thierry rosiers
nouveautés heroes et ouais bah ouais tu
trouves pas il est pour toi le prochain
prochain pas c'est bien aux pics de 33 à
atlanta le prochain tekken et dortoirs
antoine nom est pour moi celui dont le
bruno fernando au silicone c'est le gars
antoine il pleure ô il ya 35 ans tôt ou
alors il est allé triste on sait pas il
est juste ben lewis et on boys pour
fernando oui tu les aimes bien atlanta
t'adore j'adore le fait atlanta joris
tout le monde qui nous écoute votre
prochain protecteur de serre il est
l'heure il est arrivé il est gros il est
fort il jamais et s'améliore
les pieds du trou depuis deux ans pas
tant que ça et il va arriver à
travailler votre terroriser les gens
ailleurs bruno permanent c'est une
excellent choix et se justifie le fait
d'avoir repêché deux tellier en quatre
ans de cela tout à fait peut-être qu'ils
le savaient peut-être qu'ils espéraient
descendre un peu à la raf alors après il
aura pu choper nick claxton pas beaucoup
plus haut peut-être le coup de tenter
ils ont peut-être essayé d'appeler les
nets pour pour choper ni klaxon mais
pourquoi pas boll est toujours pas pris
folle folle de bruno peinado avant
balboa ça fait mal j'avoue brune bruno
fernando qui du coup contrairement à ce
que vous voyez va pas aux sixers
il va aux hawks d'atlanta et il va donc
prendre une place qui manque est
pourquoi pas dans la rotation
bah oui c'est ça c'est clair qu'ils
jouent l'année prochaine ils ont dit oui
à deadman disons personne d'autre
derrière lehman l'éruption ou un truc
comme soutien maccione ans comme ça
quand même fred jeunes c'est possible
peut-être mais omar sy spelman joue plus
4 cette année donc en jogging noir il ya
un spot en ya un spot pour bruno
fernando après ouais c'est pas le genre
de l'année mais
on s'est pas le moindre de 34 ans a très
honnête après je pense que quand il
choisit vraiment vraiment fernando
devant ball bol c'est que tu cherches
être nba ready quoi un plus bono
fernando est plus une bière et dit
beaucoup puisque le bol s'est dit wang
damon qui est free agent alors là oui
pour la vache
ouais y'a des contrats une low d'atlanta
surtout quand avec elle et ils ont
rajouté en plus salomone il à solomon et
la haine crabes
c'est ou non c'est tout mais j'en suis
turenne prins mais au final il va
falloir qui cotent sérieusement le
roster bas je pense qu'on peut dire au
revoir a dit hunter davies s'est finie
la nba
il n'y a qu'une prise vient de débuter
par ces voyous somme ben écoute je vois
un des davis alors c'est peut-être un
autre jean certes c'est un peu comme
s'il ya des fans d'atlanta dans le chat
dit nous ayons le temps difficiles et
pas même fils badine t davies il a
peut-être entre l'école doit faire peur
aux équipes dit williams dans le tchat
c'est pas faux ouais on donnait draft
est un mec qui a du goût
vestimentairement ce si important
viendrait scandalisé quand je suis je
vais m'absenter cinq minutes
erwan c'est que
bol il a fait son work out enfin arriver
là sont wes hanson elle prônait vu la
vidéo
il n'a pas fait de workout autres ouais
et son son work out privé il était il
est un jogging ou est ce que ben disais
tout à l'heure
donc sortir un jogging tu caches se
situe qu'acheter jambes donc soit parce
qu'ils la vie des gens derrière max et
lien blessés voilà où alors il cache une
blessure
si je sais pas ce qu'il en est mais s'il
a pas envoyé son rapport médical aux
équipes c'est l'athlète direct bien sûr
aidé rapport médical a pas de piquant
alexis qui nous dit que c'est bien dit
on tait davis quai dans l'effectif des
hawks à savoir comment il s'est retrouvé
là bon on verra bien donc le prochain
pic c'est le 35
il est acquis ils critiquent 35 moi je
suis perdue sur nouvelle le relais à
neuf alors là oui c'était à la base le
pic que de pas d'atlanta magnifique
magnifique seppi tu l'as vue légal mais
j'imagine tu vas être surpris alors les
on récapitule leur draft pour l'instant
pour l'instant ils ont drafté zion
williamson ils ont drafté et yves
jacques senez
ils ont drafté nickel alexander walker
muets ils ont récupéré le pic de
cleveland protéger en 2020 donc ce qui
se transformera probablement seconde
l'an 2000 21 ans quelque chose comme ça
voilà la draft des hawks dp l'icône jeu
n'importe quoi des résidents ils ont
récupéré sur la grave de la famille mais
il
ils ont maintenant les pays keynes ils
ont dégagé sur le menu mais ils ont
besoin de jouer du kite space ont besoin
des gens ont besoin de shooter pour
écarter le jeu pour écarter de jeu qui
reste à ce niveau là de la draft et
manier joutes qui reste ensuite à vue
une 35e rien qui reste son shooter en 35
min
[Musique]
qu'est le football il a mais s'est on
bosse et on bâille la fin du suspense
mark teitell etc sa gueule de confort au
pardon aux 35 brasil double arrêt au
louise
diddy lousada qu'on était parmi les
rares à avoir dans notre mode draft
alors une personne ne connait je pense
il n'a pas pleinement mois mais quid ces
deux jeunes et and given i je pense que
c'est un brésilien qui joue qui joue
toujours au brésil quatre jours au
brésil
il a 20 ans ils disent 19 mai il va voir
21-19 ennemis 19,9 l'heure il va avoir
20 ans c'est sa ford et défenseur
capable en catch and shoot est assez bon
en transition et il est fin il ils ont
les assets les tickets le shooter
compact voit quelques images très
plaisir c'est un shooteur underrated
c'est beau c'est beau ce pic des hawks
qui vont être le stage et non oui c'est
possible qu'ils aillent les tâches et
non c'est les hawks mais le stage chez
au brésil ou en europe
du coup c'est possible qu'ils le sont je
sais pas alors l'image bon les belles et
pas très bien quelle est là mais je sais
pas je pense que ça serait bien pour lui
qu'il aille en europe un peu mais je
pense qu'il n'a pas besoin d'attendre
très longtemps en europe
je pense que je le mettrais peut-être un
ou deux ans mais c'est que c'est quoi la
yam du ressort des pelikan ce bail à
peut-être une place digit ii ou iii il
joué et jouent plus 2 mai mais il peut
jouer 3 je pense que m sf et il est très
fin il est très maigre
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut qu'ils
se densifie post e3 est là et je sais
pas si les gars vous avez vu est ce
qu'il ya un seul autre live au monde qui
peut vous parler de marcos lula da silva
en français à vous dire des vrais infos
et des gens qui l'ont vu jouer
merci antoine mais on en avait parlé
dans les podcasts ans on l'avait évoqué
pour pour les pour les vrais mais il est
très dense ici je pense qu'il faut qu'il
passe au s2 en europe là je le vois bien
en espagne où un truc parce que du coup
il y aura la culture qui qui va
permettre de match est pour pour se
développer
j'aime beaucoup le shoot sur ce que j'ai
vu les images là bas non c'est bon de
transition le bon shooteur bon défenseur
c'est un vrai joueur c'est pas bruno
fernando quoi c'est pas sa classe et il
jouait depuis longtemps anciens comme
comme je l'avais prévu légal et il
l'aura envoyée à détroit pour une
contrepartie x détroit locale qu'est ce
que tu racontes belle lepic 37 des
mavericks est envoyé à detroit mais il a
dit et la hausse et au 30/06/10 les
hornets où c'est quelqu'un d'autre est
ok au 36 que dit martine thouet chez qui
du coup on est là on est qu'au dit
martin
le joueur de
nevada manu tu connais bien les vannes à
nous en parler
du coup je te perdre celui que j'ai joué
plein de fois
c'est une petite équipe et tout
normalement midnight oil réveillez vous
les gars au laquelle il y avait sur les
postes 1 2 3 et freddy martin johnson et
caleb martin le frère jumeau dit martin
qui a des chiffres un peu sous-estimé au
tir qu'à une mécanique dégueulasse pour
aller avec tout ça ouais mais qui est un
très bon passeur grand pour un meneur
donc pour la lgv allant altruiste ouais
soit très bon passeur mais voilà passeur
volontaires altruiste chute pas si
dégueulasse fort défenseur pas parce
qu'il a les outils mais parce qu'il a
une belle énergie
et puis en la vérité c'est que ça peut
faire un bon rôle player son nom il
commençait un peu à paraître dans les
derniers jours avant la draft me fait
penser à l'un des films un peu à landry
fields samples et un peu plus petits
c'est dans les six pieds cinq six pieds
six ans ouais
landry fields qui a joué précédemment et
4 way ben il y manque de coffre du côté
du palais cody boys pour moi je l'avais
en direct je n'ai vu quelques fois cette
année j'ai pas je proposerai à man show
signé là il prend les bonnes décisions
avec le ballon trop mais c'est un joueur
qui est fermement pas physique qui est
qu'il l'a aussi je trouve pour pour la
nba et je vois pas en quoi les hornets
vont l'aider à se développer je vois pas
qu'est ce que les hornets voix lui à
propos pour le prendre comme cela mais
les équipes pourra pêcher avec leur cas
cette année mais plus que jamais oui sur
du stage après
les femmes martine ils sont caleb lille
sera pas drafté je pense le frère jumeau
mais ils sont quand même à ça j'ai donc
je pense que c'est un peu c'est un peu
le bac à goli de chicago quoi ouais
ouais c'est ce jeudi l'once et là vous
avez vu ça le 1 le quatrième gardien des
chicago blackhawks
l'an dernier la parle de hockey lah pas
bob pourquoi vous a ou pas le premier le
premier gardien été blessés oui
pendant une certaine longue période le
deuxième s'est blessé avant le match
deuxième gardien wings a plutôt non
c'était blackhawks et il s'est blessé
pendant le match
enfin pendant la préparation du coup ils
sont obligés de qu'on sait que troisième
gardien qui se blesse le pont est le
troisième gardien dans le troisième
quart-temps tiers-temps par an il se
blesse et du coup il avait plus de garde
et du coup il ya ce qu'ils appellent le
fait pas le bac m'bolhi qui sont sur des
contres en fait de bénévolat de
bénévolat ah oui c'est des bénévoles
c'est des gens qui sont vos équipiers
qui sont là ils sont en gros on leur
offre la place pour venir regarder le
match pour voilà est là ok zou quoi et
du coup ce mec-là quai des queyries qui
est un mec de 37 ans qui était comptable
qu'elle joue et attire quant à elle
gagne d'ailleurs qu'elle jouait attire
tant de nhl et cas pas pris un seul but
et qui a été élu homme du match
c'est bon ça allait marcher on a dit qu
il est vivant aux mavericks du coup il
va où ils valent 2 3bis ça profitera des
trois ans souter futurs moyens qu'elle
donne nous du profil rare de là
antoine celle là on est dans ton rayon
là ça y est la cspn cemac schmitz tu m'a
posé la question il ya deux jours et je
n'étais pas du tout près j'étais en
train de faire autre chose tu dis sera
midi c'est vrai grosse énergie c'est bon
qi basket envergure négative encore
beaucoup d'européens nagano oui mais les
américains aussi un oui dow jones --le
année des t-rex l'année de direct star
revient à shoote pas mal mais sans plus
d'être à 36,37 onu roi mais là j'ai
paniqué quand la mécanique est bonne et
c'est surtout un mec qui joue dur qui
défend d'ailleurs et qui du coup il est
bon en transition puisqu'il peut voler
des ballons conférence pour ses coûts
non c'est plus ça c'est plus un vrai
poste
ouais ben oui ça peut être une cause
uruguay 3 4 moi je vois plus de trois
services as tu vois plus de 3 soit plus
de 3 ok ben toi tu aimes bien de le
joueur et puis le le fit avec détroit
oui absolument je trouve que je trouve
qui amène une énergie une agressivité
surtout en défensive qui kills très
intéressante qui est chemin ccs joie
qu'un au matin il arrête jamais jamais
jamais de bouger sur le terrain et
savoir faire changement d d d d attaque
toilette bouchée de stan van gundy
il est extrait de bouger maintenant une
belle expression de ben qui utilisent
souvent
le 30 juin près de jeu doit habiter
menzeh à les pays keynes échange le 39
aux golden state warriors à les warriors
qui ont un petit target qui selon le 41
641 là il voit il voit tu allais norton
tucker tomber et sont en train de se
frotter les mains
peut-être je sais pas pourquoi ils
tombent il ya des choses qu'on sait bien
mais la baule bol yapo [ __ ] jogging
ball ballon l'oublier mais les noms de
jay by l'asbeste available sur espn
fellay pour une fois d'accord avec lui
weaver paul le guen ce dirt eric pascale
talet norton coeur daniel gars fort de
ses cinq noms de joueurs qu'on pouvait
attendre en fin de premier tour et de
38,6 cabine séquelles psychiques heures
je crois qu'il est chou rouge et moi
j'ai vachement l'impression que non
daniel gafo daniel gars ford ok c'est
mon gars c'est le gars de manu manu
vas-y daniel ghafour delà mais c'est un
joueur que j'aime beaucoup je trouve
qu'il est bon c'est pas un shooter du
tout il est en bas il n'est pas ta tion
du profil il dépasse pas la raquette
vraiment bon rebondeur capable vraiment
actif sous le panier contreur hausse de
post 5 exactement très mobile web mobile
c'est ce que je marquais bonomelli t al
fire contreur 60 % aux lancers francs du
coup ça c'est pas ouf
et je me posais la question à l'époque
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour qu'ils
se créent un shoot 4 5 mètres dans le
futur c'est ça parce que l'adresse n'a
pas vraiment progressé et il doit être
un peu plus consistante en défense il
est pas ouais il manque un peu de force
au poste ques notamment fait rouler
dessus par charles massi cette année sa
vie oui sinon je pensais à bien à blaz
les pensées
il a roulé dessus marc dossa manteau
noir
puisque tu en penses antoine d'une bombe
à came back est consciente et ineo gaza
donc c'est on est bénéfique à chicago sa
ville de chicago il va prendre la place
du mec que les le gat chicago des tests
à caen il s'appelle le pdc haut c'est
felicio merci ah oui bah et christophe
pélissier au hockey ouais ouais c'est
moins puissant que félicien quand même
un ouais c'est pas le même physique ou
un chat même physique mais il est un peu
plus de mobilité via une meilleure
mobilité ya plus de deux longueurs et de
verticalité dans une rotation je déteste
pas du tout dany gifford ans non c'est
un peu comme mike stone un 10 minutes
par match fut tu dit vas-y défend la
moindre potentiel peut-être que clapton
il ya moins de potentiel claxton mais il
ya peut-être un peu plus de puissance
potentielle
c'est pour l'instant il a encore faim
mais je pense qu'ils peuvent vraiment
ajouter du muscle et des contrats un
intérieur un peu fort au poste parce que
en 5
ils ont qui en en ce moment ils n'ont
pas grand monde parce que wendell carter
et marquer nan c'est pas vraiment des
cinq de métier quoi c'est plus simple
petit pour être gentil réponse des
postes 4 les petits oui dany gifford en
mission en défense sur des mesures sur
des sur des
sur des pivots qui sont gênants j'achète
j'achète du côté de la bretagne
partons canada cette tâche est déléguée
a pas de chicago ouais bah absolument
absolument je trouve que je trouve que
c'est un bon back up big qui peut jouer
peut-être quinze ans cette nuit deux par
match qui vaut partager le monde à pékin
où wendel carton qui n'est pas si
différent que toute version assez trop
tôt explique que ce que de ce que wayne
tha carter fait ok eh bien écoutez je je
je vais accorder les violons avec vous
je peux vous faire chier c'est trop
moche daniel gars ford à chicago ça me
plaît non mais c'est vrai à ce moment-là
de la draft on peut commencer à drafté
pour le besoin aussi c'est plus vraiment
meilleurs joueurs de son nez sur des
tirs tellement équivalent que c'est ça
c'est ça les délais panier anti rappel
du deuxième tour peut-être pour les gens
qui suivent qui suivent sur le live
on vous remercie d'être vous êtes encore
presque 100 sur le chat génial et
l'aspect claxton 31 brooklyn ex brooklyn
nets 32 quasi okpala miami heat 33
carsen edwards boston celtics 34 bruno
fernando atlanta hawks 30
atlanta ouais elle compte 35
diddy lousada c'est pas sûr au ksk ce
site compte 5 10 10 lousada marcus lula
da silva pour être complètement précis
va à la nouvelle orléans le 36 martin va
à il va ou que dit martine messieurs
alors mais je l'avais charge de 37 des
vides a servi 10 à détroit le 38 daniel
gars ford à chicago le 39 ce sera les
golden state warriors qui vont choisir
le 40
il reste à son propriétaire je ne sais
plus qui s'était sacramento sacramento
asseyait seller de knocking ceux qui
n'ont pas con
fait de moov d'ailleurs tiens ils sont
pas essayer de monter douanes ils sont
restés tranquilles ça a peut-être leur
sourire et le 41 golden state golden
state aussi et on rappelle qu'ils
restent deux joueurs qui étaient
attendus quand même plutôt dans le top
20 25 tonnes horton tucker ball bol qui
sont encore là on ne parle même pas de
lugano d'orthe
et du coup daniel ghafour des parts il
en manquait un autre sur les cinq que
gmail à sa cité tout à l'heure j'ai
perdu le compte séparé alors qu'elle a
sur le tchat
coucou mcgregor à excellent excellent le
meilleur photographe des états unis si
vous voulez le contacter phare de
l'univers voire de l'univers entier
il est breton je crois fait partie de la
bretagne connexion cette façon elle est
la bretagne et est partout en bretagne
est partout c'est vrai en martinique je
suis il y avait un drapeau breton sur
les i minatchy complète fiba de merde
tintin drapeau breton alors que c'est à
l'autre bout du monde c'est vrai qu'il
ya le drapeau a une autre signification
aussi non chapeau rond dit marc gregor
effectivement chebah la bretagne
vive la bonne eau là qu'est ce qui se
passe ce my life my [ __ ] il étudie en
trente neuf
ouais mais ils montrent même plus market
n'y a aucun respect sur estienne ça
antoine on a parlé tout à l'heure où
hier j'ai plus de voir son burger je l'
ai parlé j'ai parlé quand on mangeait
exactement burger bacon sa mauvaise
d'ailleurs moi j'avais fait de bons
essais ce moment là bas dit apparemment
les warriors sont choses sur ce alex
miles aldridge qui était en j league
mais qui pouvait pas être drafté il a
passé un an de j league
c'est un pivot assez brut encore ouais
c'est un pivot très brute qui est
toujours physique pour l'instant ouais
y'a pas il n'y a pas encore vraiment le
shoot il fait encore énormément de
fautes très naïve mais quand
golden state à essayer de choper le pit
41 ça sentait le ça sentait le coup
fourré sachant que c'est l'heure des
kings attend sa maille la guinée is back
in avait été caché par les warriors
oui il était retourné en europe
directement en serbie casting james
geste intel d'avoir à me wade de ce bar
que je ne connais pas du tout waouh
et bah lui on va pas être capable de
vous mettre un profil je n'ai jamais
connaissais pas du tout le chai à temps
mais allen smile aguiche non plus là on
rentre dans du territoire inconnu un
petit coup une plage peut pas actualisés
connaît pas c'est pas grave tu mettras
le prochain mais ok justin james les
kings les kings fans
on est désolé désolé pour qu on appelait
julien korver est potentiellement
capable de l'avoir vu jouer
non j'ai vu jouer un match de wyoming en
décembre et débats mémoire mais je
savais même pas si j'ai pas tilté tu
vois j'ai des joueurs quand je regarde
des matches de 2e et de belley je ne
note pas toujours des trucs qu'il ya des
matches je regardais je suis là en mode
découverte quoi et là j'avais à noter ce
justin james bond
donc j venu en voici stade 22 points 8
rebonds 4 passes
c'était un gros scoreur dans une petite
fac pendant une petite mare je vous
donnais sa taille 6 7
donc c'est très bon s'est fait de mettre
un peu de m 1 185 ses maigres fait quoi
c'est 125 kg voit dans ces eaux là c'est
très maigre
c'est un senior il est né en 97 donc
22 ans et demi vingt deux ans et demi
donc là je suis sur un site qui
s'appelle nba scouting live j'ai peur là
c'est pas souvent que ça nous arrive
mais alors là on est on est quoi voilà
comment tu peux après je veux bien mais
on post 2 tu as un mec comme quelqu'un
qui est disponible kwa knk l'est norton
tucker
je pense qu'il est humble sic un
mini-album la plus grave pour l'instant
le vrai joueur qu'à glisser c'était bon
album
il avait un problème physique et l'autre
talonneur tone tout cas on sait pas trop
pourquoi donc qui n'est toujours pas
fatigué de faire des aller retour toutes
les deux minutes
il ya des bons mollets mais eric autant
chez les warriors ça fait plutôt du sens
je lève et angoisse
tu l'as vence du coup il lui il lui
tournaient autour de plus un petit bull
ouais je les ai vus je crois sur la mode
henri iv au début de la semaine ou
quelque chose du genre
c'est pas s'est passé pas c'est pas
étonnant c'est c'est pas le meilleur
joueur du monde il sait tout faire
tiens genre de devoir par luigi l'imac
machine cie horton car il est criminel
s'il un casier mal mais je sais pas on
suivra mais en tout cas on sait pas qui
est de justin james et c'est
probablement quelqu'un qui était en
prison en maintenant un mec comme justin
james
c'est un peu comme justin robinson 7 tu
les oublient vite c'est justin s'est
dénoncé des non tu vois qu'ils sont
tellement passe partout c'est un peu
relou
toi tu voulais jouer au jeu des facs
tout à l'heure et a pas pu du coup tu es
frustré non non parce que je sais gproms
différé je vous avais j'avais l'image
quelques minutes que quelques minutes en
différé donc je voyais la première de
ginette quand j'en parle de l'a3 leur
hymne dance junior son épouse s'appelle
et il y pense ce cette vidéo commence à
ressembler à n'importe quoi c'est le
wyoming les cow boys du wyoming est dans
merde hole wyoming te sont à des cow
boys des vaches un donc des cow boys et
des vaches et des cow boys qui gardent
les vaches donc pour s'identifie sté un
peu mieux de s'identifier des cowboys
plutôt qu'à des vaches
nous en sommes aux pics 42 messieurs
après ça manu je t'ai pas demandé eric
pascal golden state
ouais c'est un jour qui s'était fondu
dans la masse à villanova qui avait
vraiment vrai vrai rôle de mec ultra
puissant énergique que tu capable de
nous un peu tout faire avec avec nova 42
à washington field alors alors l'examen
jour nous a appris quelque chose alors
admiral ce copil il faut savoir que
c'est un joueur qui est né dans la même
maternité que les deux princes
d'angleterre c'est à dire william et
harry et sa flore tant de souvenirs de
leurs noms vous des milices william
harris des notaires commun à chaque fois
j'ai peur d'oublier mais williams qui
est marié à kate middleton
fonctionnement et qui est marié à meghan
markle admire asco filmé et aurait pu
finir avec megan marque
on est d'accord celui qui scorent son
meghan markle
dylan one admiral semaine il est pucé
crise mais middleton ou meghan markle
mega cd reprend des textes fegan markala
semble donc aux médias il alors j'aurai
assez de ce que vous en pensez l''achat'
on vote
meghan markle d'un côté
et c'est qu'il autres kate middleton de
l'autre donner vos avis kate middleton
un peu plus de classe selon moi une
belle tenue de coût de cette draft
commence à ressembler à une grave de
football américain eric pascal admiral
schofield là on est en train de racheter
les cubes pour tôt que des joueurs admis
rask fils et un cube bas le problème
admira schofield c'est une bonne idée
le problème d'un cube c'est que ça roule
pas bien non j'aime bien il s'est fait
en fait c'est gratuit willems eu pauvres
de tennessee avait des joueurs très
similaires schofield et et grande foule
m pardon sont très similaires très hyper
tank est petit pour leur poste ce que
fils d'un petit plus sur le shoot exter
il s'en ait un meilleur shooteur et
williams très puissant mais bah il a
essayé de la taille pour la pour la nba
j'en doute
là les pieds plats ils sabotent meghan
markle dans le chat et on nous informe
que dans les ouailles homing sont pas
des vaches ce sont des bisons ah c'est
vrai j'aimerais bison futé d'ailleurs
certains week-ends dans l'ensemble c'est
pas très loin d'ici
dans l'ensemble les dix ont fédéré le
truc du trafic routier chez nouvelle a
dû vite j'ai aucune idée de ce que vous
parlez ben oui admiral schofield qui
atterrit à washington du gouffre oui
absolument
donc qu'est ce que tu en penses j'irai
pas échus devriez draft deux gars qui
peuvent jouer en 3 et 1 4 mais
majoritairement à 4 et je sais pas
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent faire avec ça
je crois qu'il va se ramasser dans
l'eure dans leur rotation mais parce
qu'au fil du vent de fiers services mais
là je m'excuse les gars je suis vraiment
obnubilé par ce sujet quelques minutes
d'arras au fouet et le choix 44 et
probablement gelé
meyrin un des trois mais des trois
minutes de télévision les plus étranges
et pour pourquoi c'est ça que tu fais
mais on est toujours on ne connaît pas
le picard en toi on met des gens au
hasard mais c'est quelque chose pour que
vous regardez c'est la pub shin beth ceu
tête une étrangeté absolument adorable
dans ce cas le bon bout bison futé égale
grizzlies rusé au québec si toi c'est
bien vu donc 43 qui est-ce qui choisit
en 43 voilà vous à la photo d'avenir à
ce qu field qui a des gros bras il va
faire le arnold classic la séquence en
septembre c'est pour les body builder le
jour se lève en france aujourd'hui je
vais faire voir vers minuit ici vous on
a passé la nuit
vous êtes encore chaud sur le sur le
chat vous êtes vous moins que les
insomniaques façon à cette heure-là les
gens qui se lèvent tôt
on en train de discuter avec romain qui
nous dit c'est n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi je pense qu'il est choqué comme
nous sur les sols épique et d'eau qui
espionnent par exemple qui met une pub
je suis sûr qu'elle épique qui sont en
train de tomber un mais alors donc pour
revenir à un sujet un peu plus sérieux
historiquement antoine entre 40 et 60
les chances de réussite sont pas rares
sites un joueur juste des as qui intègre
une rodas une rotation et qui joue sept
minutes c'est bien je pense que dans le
taiwan entre da pour l'instant il ya qu
eric pascal sur les trois qui ont été
drafté quoi et qui va intégrer une
relation claire
ouais mais le fils jett pas du tout
j'aime bien joueurs nés pour les nz y
ait une puissance est bien mais il faut
être un peu verticale quand apple a
taillé pour ton pasqua après il ya un
vrai il ya un vrai bel état d'esprit
il ya un vrai tournant de serviettes
potentiel schofield goûts et ses gros
bras
imaginez la vitesse de rotation à 5 une
belle mort plus de 5000 et les poignets
alaïa dumousseau témoigne alors qu'une
belle mort serait pas mal d'argent
atteint maintenant ils sont plus des
salles est maintenant il joue mais bon
c'est à atlanta ben il ya une question
de le chat tu préfère citer bol tu
préférais draft et maintenant on pas
être drafté du tout moi je pense que ce
n'est pas de tracter du tout et il va
s'arrêter de jouer au basket
marie dans le même s'il est pas drafté
du temps alors on s'éclaire mais non je
prépare être je préparais le reste est
maintenant alors le 43è ce qu'il est
vraiment à miami où est ce qu'il est
ailleurs
minnesota minnesota
quant à trois pics de retard par chez
nous chez nous avec riesch chris weitz
dans ma mode draft que je détestais pas
comme tu dis ben et voilà 43 43 4 il
annonce le 44 qui va dès demain à ouïr
garde est mis au sol
c'est quelque chose là regardez bien
cette montée vers le stage baseball aux
biches y est
ohlala et on est en train de vie c'est
incroyable avait si elle est l'invitée
bon sens il va aussi m'aider madame
hélène l accès surbaissé du coup dans
son costume de michael jackson c'est
d'une tristesse infinie qui a été
choisie en 43 il est là erwan attend
tiens tiens tu va réagir à la tvh album
album en 44 et roanne c'est un style je
pense vraiment que tu admires des
cithares que ça d'ailleurs
moi ce qui me plaît
et d'honneur et connaissances qu'ils ont
drafté mec péter un mec cassé ouais je
pense que j'ai peur que de ça s'il est
si bas quand on voit les stars et
confèreront voit qu'il a fait neuf
matchs cette saison
ouais je pense qu'il est cassé et avec
michael porter junior je crois que d'un
puissant les amis il aime bien prendre
des lacs brisé quoi il est cassé il est
castré puisque alain jacques marescaux
gros taf en tout cas merci à one sur les
bords du rhône chez andrew albicy qui
voit jouer l'euroligue la sas une info
sont maintenant on y va ça va mais n'a
plus roulé en sait pas compter le 46e va
être fait là n'ont dit si tu y vas
dormir là juan tient non mais après si
l'analyse marcus cédric en 45 inquiété
john noël j'aime bien mais où minnesota
moi j'aime bien mais aussi les pics
temps qu'on les a maintenant je dis oui
fatigue est là il fait jour la nuit il
était en pleurs éléments étaient pas
perdre leurs devoirs il est monté on a
une vraie question plutôt meghan markle
où kate middleton meggen marque en tout
cas tous les jours c'est oui c'est du
100%
voilà bah je crois que les deux
princesses ont été départagés je
connaissais le piqueur razali un vrai
avantage
d'abord car je connais pas à zahia
robbie 45-45 zahia robbie qui va ou das
à 0 un style effectivement isaiah robbie
[ __ ] de mega style et 46 à 40 chez les
lakers
ils ont acheté le site us et 48 sa belle
non non c'est 46 46
ils ont acheté et ouais et on achète un
pic donc il va être le quatrième jeu
et le 47 des knicks et je sème regarde
pas les ententes de coria les profils et
les mois suivants brut car ces sacrifiés
knicks pourquoi lengert face à
sacramento sur six
nick speak english and in gaasbakk des
kiss non mais faut-il séveno et brassent
des quiches et aurélien n'était ce pas
ben on a besoin de viande
au deuxième tour on avait besoin d'un
autre ailier qui était capable de jouer
3 potentiellement cap et c'est un gars
c'est un gros costaud c'est un gars qui
est capable de jouer sans le ballon
donc moi je suis je suis je suis
correcte avec cette sélection la même
cette firme est clairement qui est pied
avec mj bats est décédé fighter quoi
c'est des mecs qui vont yvon charbonneau
c'était méchant et ils ont dit de
méchant
maintenant vous avez des méchants mais
en espérant qu'on est con et pour
échanger family qui n'a pour je mets
rien devant notre je sais pas s'ils ont
acheté je suis en région très b quelque
chose pour la voir ok après six essais
de phase i pour moi c'est un style qui
ont géré ce jeu c'est de voir ce qui
s'est passé mais mais mais mais c'est
vrai aussi un canadien aussi en tout cas
c'est cesser new york sur ontario la cdc
lainière niagara
les trams heures la moitié la moitié à
new york la moitié au canada ouais ok
qu'est ce que tu peux dire aux gens du
live sur ignacio rasd et qui se mène à
saint jouin qui est dieu qui est
physique qu un peu la même genre de
physicalité qu'un josh à getafe
avait entier les gros épaules
il bouscule il dérange c'est peut-être
un joueur explosif mais un joueur ce
joueur qui joue donc moi moi moi j'aime
beaucoup je pense qu'il va bien il faut
bien rentrer dans la philosophie des
knicks mcgregor qui a pris la photo
d'inès brasse des kiss qui est sur notre
site d'air et qui est sur le chat parce
qu'il était photographe de michigan
cette année qui connaît bien l'équipe
donc et qui fit dit c'est surtout un jeu
un joueur qui pousse ses partenaires
accord cessa pas physiquement qui
encourage les partenaires sans vrai
leader marc grégoire fois confirmé mais
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui n'hésite pas
ouvrir sa gueule qui a envie de gagner
et encore une fois ce fait du bien la
culture nick baynes bah oui c'est clair
selon channel il aurait échangé
seulement 55 peau donc je ne sais pas si
ça cache forcément du cache derrière 48
cyclisme and well poche
bah si certaines semaines clippers fait
peur j'ai peur qu'il se mette bien jouer
à 100% clippers étaient huntsman
ouais tu n 10 jours de sorties surtout
dit mais mais mais mary capot tout de
suite à une bière et dis donc je dis
aime tuer on vous l'avait mis dans le le
spread des trente ans 280 pour ce qui va
avoir notre twitter
c'était un autre aspect style du second
tour joueur qui était d'ailleurs ils
viennent de draft et deux coéquipiers
les clippers ont drafté les deux florida
state kabengele tennisman effectivement
kabengele terrance man donc florida
state façon c'est du site du joueur qui
qui ce bac et physique
kim et des brins si les bras manu est
d'accord sur l'idée states avait des
bras oui ma nuit les fous du rouleau
bois il est affalé là dans le jeu veut
nier ou là il veut me honni et je crois
que ça arrivera nick algayon il veut il
veut me haut niveau et il veut aller où
ils allaient au delà corbett c'est la
vidéo c'est validé la vidéo donc on est
des gens qui commencent à se réveiller
sur twitter
la food et yannick mtl on va mettre
on va mettre 1,8 ou à m nous on est
toujours debout et vous vous vous levez
voilà à faire ouais c'est vrai quand
j'en ai flou des là disons on va dormir
comme en 14
fodé l'amiante hutin maire
ça fait bizarre de voir un titre en
français depuis le temps quoi
alors comme on a commencé lui lui marc
tatum non lui c'est si le monsieur k 10
q et lesbienne au deuxième c'est un cap
analystes c'est bobby marx bobby à
thibaut big bob et max boublil marie léa
letten il est excellent c'est vraiment
un mec talentueux mais d'ailleurs c'est
lui qui a formé kyle gaïa la
comptabilité quasiment furet le
quatrième gardien de tiago de la galaxie
absolument 49 on l'a pas travaillé chez
les ch et les nuts voilà pendant un bout
de 48 heures en semaine c'est ça oh
allez oust et la peur est là on attend
toujours le 49 qui va dans quel état au
49 les spurs qui prennent les meilleures
de nom de tous les temps all time
cundari witherspoon mississippi state
c'est pareil on après j'étais si si si
on a un profil de kundry nain scouting
report de condom on n'a pas de ce que tu
me racontes derrière bien c'est pas
sérieux c'est un arrière il faut ne pas
wec et pas forcément très bons futurs
que pas forcément bon quelque part
d'ailleurs il défend il ouais mais là
pas de chance
mba les arrières comme paciotti du coup
je les black list lui un confrère qu'est
ce que tu veux faire c'est black list et
son frère qui s'appelle nouvelair spoon
[Rires]
cuillère du temps cuillère de l'abbé
laconique et j'ai fait sans tricher
queen de rehab
après c'est un gros travailleur un
kinder il a fait deux cent mille burqa
août et 52 points au scrabble fait leurs
achats
et ouais au scrabble et 5 y est
les commentaires les commentaires vous
êtes magique dans les commandes
c'est sur steam car à millery cap assez
for sim caméra capte rom avec ses stocks
inutile voie légale et mettre des
pousses bleu sur la vidéo de force team
franchement c'est un régal
il nous laisse le plateau pour toute la
nuit et ce sera de faire des blagues
testons même temps faire des blagues
tesla va c'est des gens qui connaissent
le basket c'est des gens qui nous ont
fait confiance pour venir avec eux sur
leurs vidéos qui nous ont fourni du rosé
ils nous ont fourni du rosé ils nous ont
régalés vraiment un gros big up à la
force team à 6 heures du matin alors
qu'ils n'ont pu la 25e sérieusement 27e
chaussée ainsi laissé le sait comme
d'habitude la pub des 27e fois qu'on la
voit cette pub pour la wnba elle a alors
regardé à double nba c'est bien mais
arrêtez de mettre des pubs de la wnba
s'il vous plaît ça mais c'est le les
ligues pas c'est toujours les mêmes que
ouais c'est le leak passe de quoi cspn
qui choisit les pubs non ça c'est le
leak passe assez league pass 1 c'est
pour ça qu'il a pu bec brent barry put
alors est-ce que puisqu'on peut on va
écrire quelques secondes positive à bôle
voilà ce que là franchement sens du look
up c'est vrai il était au bord du
suicide comme anti analyse cette
capacité de déplacement là je patine rip
en déplacement de la chaise juste les
pour société jusqu'aux puppy c'est pour
ce que je sais que je serai pas capable
de parler par l'accord est soudainement
abed
c'est après de regarder bol monter son
exécutif et kate moss et les pantalons
de michael jackson qui était kiki
cabella de lui restreint les hanches
alors qu'il allait chercher sa casquette
au deuxième talkie walkie me fend le
coeur il avait des petits petit pantalon
comptait pas toutes petites jambes et
c'était presque aussi triste que son
sourire
qu'est ce qui se passe avec qu'est ce
qui se passe avec telenor tucker les
gars vous avez vu des news pas
ces logiciels de retard et après 46 et
voilà c'est pas non plus il est bercé ne
sais pas c'est juste du pur potentiel
cndd bref tous les gens ils ont beaucoup
enfin quand tu vas cody martin où ils
ont passé des valeurs sûres c'est vrai
beaucoup de valeurs sûres comme serveur
c'est vrai du coup dont ils ont commencé
comme johnson 11 et après c'était
c'était la foire la foire à
l'emporte-pièce et saison prochaine
parce qu'ils ont absolument personne bah
pour moi il peut défendre dès l'année
prochaine
ah oui c'est clair et moi pas sur le
monde mais il est il a tort pour
défendre nos plus grands il a
l'envergure et il a les pieds pour
défendre sur des joueurs de sa taille
donc là on voit sur espn qui dit mais il
y brassent des kiss en power forward
quand même oui pour un non non c'est
plus assez bon allez chez le suspect
fait 6 7 jours ouais c'est plus un poste
3 mme bah ouais c'est bon 3 on va
demander à marc gregor mcgregor cite
encore là nous confirme poste 3 3 me
après je dis peut se décale par par
séquences mais bon les pivots ont pris
cher dans cette draft qu'on dit williams
est vrai et ça confirme un peu une
tendance générale au comme on dit à un
pic cinq ans là le pic 50 est rentré
chez un autre choix que ce que les
punchs to have a dit il ça s'appelle un
watt jarrell quoi
je sais je sais même pas 2 à 6 ans est
lougansk toujours pas de racheter un
temps tomba je vais être assez 3 nous
dit marc accord pour iggy évidemment on
connaît les buy autant justin james
wyoming tout ça sous le nom de vite fait
mais j'ai voyagé aucun souvenir
autant j'ai mal brinkley je n'ai même
pas vu pour une minute je n'ai pas vu
une seule minute
c'est donc les celtics 51 très bonne
twitter est excellent choix mais pour
avoir ils ont paralysé l'huma ils ont
cartonné world
mais derrière ils se ressemblent waters
excellent jeu water c'est pas là j'adore
mon meilleur joueur disponible aussi
poste
ouais vas-y vas-y ben mais vous savez qu
est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui est le
drame avec trent water et géographiques
sont sélectionnés c'est qu'ils ont été
sélectionnés mariage chayotte mais pas
sélectionné encore ouais bien d'autres
gens qui sont passés venait d'ailleurs
c'est pas grave pour powers
c'est toi qui m'avait dit que ce cas pas
de racheter un
je l'avais j'avais mis un 51e il ya au
sur vos borde le match que moi je
pensais que les quais étaient en 51
louis king bazire et il est sur le
potentiel qu'on prenne un coup du plomb
dans l aile
je pense que je suis moins qu'il aimait
paul jacques norvège et je pense qu'il y
avait là la forme de la g-league lucien
et les fêtes et des mairies contrat et
que du coup ils étaient tous et que du
coup les équipes se traîne brembo mais
nous citons boys
une bonne toujours pas là john mack
daniel salaün aldridge calgary john
robinson john t porter visiblement sous
le charme au leap onze personnes va
tenter donc waters boston lie encore un
très bon salaire petit zainab ouais
ouais très bon petit à petit on en a
parlé
les forces et faiblesses là sur l'image
de très bonnes twitters sa seule
faiblesse et qu'il est petit c'est vrai
que c'est presque sa seule faiblesse en
fait ce qui fait 1 76 boire un peu moins
d'1 80 m et 2,18 à les mêmes est très
petit on chauffe le rond bon qi basket
bon passeur excellent défenseur très
humain très active
il paie le cercle alors qu'il est tout
petit il peut shooter meneur d'hommes
enders underrated je pense ce qui a pas
besoin de la taille des fois tapie n'en
a pas besoin du kontic ique saint jory
saillie frais 4 cm de plus ils se
réfèrent spica données timide mais bol
15 cm de bolton drafted ça va peut-être
sa voiture de les sourires et à bâle
vols au départ car assez a tué 23 13
seiko bastille qui annonce qu'elle gagne
aux sixers qui n'ont ses soeurs mec chat
qui est qui c'est plus un souhait qu'une
annonce à lavau jugement et ne reste de
huit pick
alors dépêchez vous les gens achètent
jeu langage c'est vrai que là on est sur
quoi on est sur quatre heures et demie 1
on a commencé à une arène avec les
ferries ont commencé à 1h30 ouais mais
mais mais mais ça fait cinq heures 5
heures passées un peu c'est un peu
longuet j'enverrai un sms adam silver je
dirais pas rejeté le champagne que tu
m'envoies garde la porte voix mais mais
enlève les publie
non c'est vrai que c'était c'était
beaucoup moins supportable on espère
qu'on vous a rendu ça un peu plus
agréable parce que les pubs sur espionne
c'est quand même très long et on a dû
meubler quand même beaucoup
alors qu'on ne devrait pas avoir à le
faire normalement ça s'enchaîne ça va
vite
là j'aurai chez moi je me sens encore
bien
ouais bah oui on est debout par la force
des choses de dire quand on commence
quelque chose dans le fini mais oui il
est là il ya du trade à la con qui sait
le genre ouais c'est très vite 58 pour
le pays que 59 et des trucs comme ça
c'est quand même c'est comme la fin
d'une partie où est-ce qu'il ya trop ça
n'a aucun sens yovel ousmane sow déborde
qui est pas trop drafté pour l'instant
on vient nous mène d'autre part becker
je suis désolé mais quelqu'un les jours
gris je sois terence davies dacquois
jeffries charme ripples ouais ouais
justin robinson justin robinson dedrick
lawson dans une moindre mesure dans le
district le sol en bref c'est un gros
tacle c'est le jour de kansas dedrick
lawson qui qu'a fait une belle saison et
comme c'est statistiquement parlant je
jure polop joueurs pour l'europe
très bon joueur de monaco dans trois ans
un grand qui peut shooter et capa de
kaki peut pas sauter au dessus d'un
bottin comme dirait ben
tame leur pub mais qui est alors qu'à
qui vont alors attendez on va faire un
petit récap parce que moi je comprends
rien justin james a été drafté par les
kings avec un pic 40
eric pascal aux 41 il va où admira
schofield 42 washington child noël 43
dallas c'est ça non au minnesota
non mais l'auteur boys boys boys boys 44
y va où
mais dès 9 heures isaiah robbie 45 da
lage dallas ça oui c'est lui dallas
talenton tucker 46 aux lakers 47e' gnass
brasse des kiss on évoque knicks
absolument terence man 48 creepers 49
queen d'harry witherspoon spurs 50 le
fameux soldat inconnu jarrell brantley
je sais même pas dans quelle famille
jouez pas au chalet brand new eyes ou
tabac il doit être blanc oui
non non il est blanc il est noir lors il
est noir il jouait vraiment water 51 ans
aux celtics dj l'allemagne à 52 charles
est alors john broadley jouer à chat
china gas chattanooga tâche est quoi
glacer s'est situé matam louga
chattanooga choo beng chattanooga au
aucun hasard si je ne m'abuse à on va
vérifier les compétences géographiques
de ben jelloun mecque dernière
c'est dans le tennessee à terme si j'ai
raté c'est pas très loin ça s'écrit avec
goûter et deux eaux il a l'air d'avoir
200 ans sur sa faute
c'est tout ce que je peux dire qui est
grand père mais les gars du wimax
danièle seux drafté en 52 à challenge
quand même et foreman en 53 par hamon
lui je connais je n'ai pas vu beaucoup
mais je le connais oui justin mike
foreman c'est le meilleur d'austra ça
c'est ça ouais ouais j'ai le stand for
men avant lugano
ouais après il shoote mieux kluge noces
d'or ouais
et c'est pareil les graffeurs énorme et
daphné en or caoutchouc s'est jetée 52
tu m'as dit 52 c'était mcdaniels sa
charlotte un we did in de rien fidji
washington jack daniel's vous avez envie
de profil un peu
il avait besoin de lui et wayne
intérieure et pas dégueulasse comme
draft en bas mcdonnell 152 matchs des
wii ouais moi aussi et pitt géant 12
pareil et ojej charlotte bas et mais
j'adore les scouts du tas je sais pas
quel tafi fond quel est le poids mais tu
sens qu'il ya un truc pas pareil que
dans les autres franchises quoi est-ce
que de gérer le band clé est justin wait
for man oui oui ça sort pas de la tête
du gm quoi oui absolument
après de là à ce qu'ils aient raison on
n'en est pas là mais je 80 visionnage en
cours aulas est incroyable après
peut-être peut-être en train de vous
lever et on a une photo de justin right
for man mais on n'a pas donné à tout le
monde il est là avec il est dégueulasse
ce maillot daube strange des pires
maillot
joe n'est plus là maillot de saint
vallier comme dirait romain nous
écoutera peut-être très fine quoi
l'équipe dans la drôme mène s'arrête pas
ici parce que c'est que la drôme
c'est un département qui est située pas
loin de là où je suis né et s'est pas
étonné ouais mais c'est dans le sud est
ce le quart sud est de la france
oui c'est la démarcation entre le le sud
est pas le sud
c'est à dire que en dessous c'est le sud
y fait chaud et en dessus il fait un
climat normal est bas en dessous de
montélimar quai dans la drôme fait chaud
voilà est-ce que ses prémices c'est
devant nice c'est vraiment tout au sud
eu d'accord à nice c'est vraiment chiant
à l'extrême sud à la côte et de l'italie
je sais pas de quoi on parle on parle de
saint vallier donc quand les mailhoc
obstrat la fac de justin right for man
qui a été choisi
53 ce très bon jeu qui joue dans la
conférence de quoi la conférence quelle
conférence se demande quelle conférence
rio ce traître via trivia obstrat la
drôme pays du nougat nous dit toutefois
c'est vrai c'est vrai sur le tchat
je crois qu'on paiera cash américaine et
athlétique n'importe quoi pourquoi cacha
mais c'est pas ça la réponse serait que
ces coloniale est l'éthique ya louis
samedi quelque chose attendez je suis
pas sûr obstrat basketball sap
on est en train de tricher en direct
lors du red bull air va t'il été sur le
college of à charleston coloniale
athletica se cherche elle est agent clé
donc quitter at charleston
oui c'est une équipe de colonial donc
qui connaît sans doute justin est donc
en fait les l'escale
ils ont fait une conférence minaj fait
une seule reprise concis et on va drafté
deux mecs de cette conférence c'est lui
c'est tout sachant que bon c'est ok
c'est de la mine manager mais on s'est
quand même limite de la lo mejor comme
un niveau là de charleston je compte
bien se réveiller les rejoindre le chat
mais suis pas sûr mais en même temps je
les ai vus actif sur twitter donc c'est
bon les copains là il faut se dépêcher
il nous reste six pick passe la seconde
ces deux langues
grégory répond aux questions à nos
places sur sur le feu
les ivoiriens ont qu à mark mathews
c'est vrai matthews il pense que ça tu
aideras des ligaments bas il reste iris
losert s'il reste le prochain jeu soit
c'est qui et dans ce cas je l'aimais 54
belle cote a tenu les comptes des
grandes capes
comment tu draft c'est à dire au moins
24 et pas quelle game et où tu disais
que tu es content de ta job vous et
sachez bien géré mais méité
oui mais c'est juste que kagame dont on
en est donc à la télé marc tatum est en
train d'annoncer john mack d'aniane ce
qui est le choix 52 non un choix 54g
rien je remplis ma petite feuille wawel
soins
ils sont à la rue complet et ça nous
arrange pas il gravit d'ornement gaveau
je trouve que je suis de la bdp qui pour
le tour des franchises qui élèvent pour
la liqueur on envoie un message adam
silver parce que la lie en a marre euh
ben ce qui est l'équipe qui choisit en
j'ai du mal à trouver ses passions fils
il avait fait la veille
il affiche pourquoi c'est n'importe quoi
je veux dire un nombre de trade
ah oui j'ai des traits de merde 50
contre 53 4
et puis et puis on s'en fout et qui
marche tu te les pubs qu'ils ont rajouté
je trouve ça très injuste parce qu'il
est d y ait des équipes qu'on deux
minutes pour choisir leur pic et on a
d'autres qu'on change 1 minute ouais il
ya des frontaux fiche pour ça c'est
l'autre et oui on n'est pas égal ego et
gars devant le chronomètre et des
highlights de michael rsa meubles bon
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on en
dit sur le chat en ce moment jay leno
fin de carrière nous dit luigi plus dur
il va peut-être signer un contrat faut
pas oublier que c'est pas parce qu'on
n'est pas drafté qu'on a qu'on est en
fin de carrière
au contraire je pense qu'il ya pas mal
de gens qui vont être un drap ci de là
qu'ils vont avoir des biens meilleures
positions tas d'exemples bas wes
matthews
non mais là deux septennats de cette
année qu'on verra qui a mais il va y
avoir énormément qui vont être en très
petit temps et on a encore jane ordre
dans le sait ça sert marianne chayotte
qu'il est là il est là oui 37 ans à
l'heure où l'on parle mariale chez ioc
qui est née sous ronald reagan
[Rires]
effectivement il est pas très jeune et
non mariale chaillac joueurs d'iowa
state donc le coéquipier de talais
norton tucker d'ailleurs lyndal
harrington
lyndal harrington je pense que la vue
les joueurs qui restent on va oublier
absolument marielle chayotte belle
petite présentation
elle fait pas de mal je crois que c'est
un poste 3 maillage étroit pas ce troyen
il c'est un signe à ce qu'on peut dire
déjà way qui joue managua state qui a
vraiment là qui est d'ottawa au canada
donc c'est notre 5/6 canadiens choisis
je crois et kiala qui alla d'avoir 48
heures 3 il avait alors 24 ans habile à
bientôt 24 cents ouais donc là je sais
25 et au pas pour les étrangers ne l'est
et les cévennes teachers c'était les
sixers maria chèques aux six ans ça a du
sens il s'échoue t il ses shoots et je
vais je vais mettre sur son profil je
vous donner quelques stats quelques
petits mais bon des rythmes et des loups
dirt des gens comme ça qui sont
disponibles et arrête de déconner
abandonné quoi l'odeur tu sais faire et
le fait que je sais pas [ __ ] on va
être pouvoir compter sur le comportement
au gem meta mais on n'a pas le pic c5r
plaisir celui qui a gagné notre notre
concours
une sieste année qui s'appelle alex
d'ailleurs
qui est fan de ucla qui aime beaucoup de
jeunes il est sauf à voir john ince et
a55 et il va où 56 66 et qu'il 55
on sait pas encore mais n'importe quoi
mais jen en ce oui j'aime beaucoup parce
qu'il a bien progressé sur la
distribution pour toronto
bien vu les choletais cac 40
genève et miami ont jeté les mieux vaut
y aura peut-être qaïda et on vous en a
parlé et reparlé re re parler
qu'est ce qu'il a dit kai kai champion
un dossier qu'elle gaye
bravo à toi mon frère excellente draft
de des kinks bac selon qu'ils y ont
drafté justin james à un long débat ils
ont une très fier cabinet oui oui même
posté suffi au deuxième tour tu restes
là megan est bien juste je comprends pas
pourquoi ils ont pas fait inverse
ben parce qu'ils pouvaient c'est juste
pour montrer aux autres poèmes moi je
peux donc des leurs 56 poursuit
description c'est intéressant a manner
arles et si les grands pas super
l'athletic mais il est grand et long et
sa photo il peut shooter il peut il peut
distribuer et il a vraiment beaucoup
progressé a surtout à l'aide à la mène à
cette année et en défense est moins bien
mais offensivement il a il a vraiment
apporté ils ont un très bon
offensive pnns avec avec kenz deux t5 et
quelques trucs comme ça c'est pas mal ok
donc giants cac a progressé
il perdait beaucoup de ballons pendant
sa première année c'est s'est améliorée
au pentagone en mille il a fait
quasiment x 3 sur mon d'assister tous
d'accord on va aller voir mariale
chayotte pour les fans de phily 38% à 3
points 81 8 aux lancers francs cette
année c'est pas mal c'est celui d'un
c'est très solide
euh ok très bien longtemps ce cas m 16
d'envergure ouais vraiment pas mon mot
de vercel mémé shire qui il fera ce
qu'il a à faire même si ses longs bras
et aux astana
même si c'est m 5 points par match
chèque et le froid
ouais c'est un espèce de cols bleus
comme on les aime bien
donc on a dit james qui se dirige vers
on ne sait qui c'est qui 56 brooklyn
brooklyn au clean qui se retrouve avec
ni klaxon et giles pour un dollar au
deuxième tour un sophomore la 19,7 gêne
c'est jeune c'est juin 97 d'envergure 1
91 ans tu as pas fou c'est bien c'est
bien c'est bien y effectivement il passé
de 2,6 passes décisives à 6 un peu plus
de turn over 1,8 à 3,2 après voilà le
pourcentage d'assister très
impressionnant 36% à 6 c'est beaucoup il
reste à ta lancée et le pourcentage de
turnover a pas beaucoup augmenté donc
donc effectivement une belle progression
qui peut laisser envisager une
progression qui continue surtout qui
devrait pas trop avoir de pression à
brooklyn sûr il va sans doute est en
tout est d'ailleurs déjà l'analyse c'est
possible mais ça dépend de ses dépenses
et pas trop ce qui va advenir à brooklyn
au niveau des surtout au niveau de la
des postes d'arrières kaïré irving ce
qui vient s qui vient pas tng leur seul
ait ce qui paraît ce qui part pas une
soeur du midi à leur parti pour rester
en revanche mais mais john hayes présent
donc l'année prochaine dans l'effectif
des nas
elle est en vrai un autre jeune maman on
veut un autre challenge lui ment on veut
un deuxième français comme il en avait
point 55 ces poudres et je sais que nous
louer mais bon ils ont traîné leur pic
pour les chercher bresse d'ekis ce qui
fait sens mais bon je donc je pense que
la fenêtre pour mon coca s'est refermée
mais mais bon maintenant on veut et ses
bains et c'est marrant parce qu'il n'ya
pas beaucoup il ya même eu quasiment pas
de stage à bhl ya pas belle mais il n'y
a pas de zuma n'y a pas de
il ya servi 10 à 37 il n'y a pas de jeu
c'est jc 29 mai c'est pas pour les
tâches et en europe chez angie ligue se
voyait de jvc a peut-être que la vraie
conséquence de ces contrats tout et sait
aussi qu'il ya moins de joueurs qui vont
être taché ou au jeu mais wow jamais
chez des allées des pk chaque de paix
que ma base annoncée et nucor prendre le
micro
emanuel fire la pique 57 58 58 et 57
c'est qui bon c'est pas oisif eschyle 58
est donc lié aux hells bon fanboy les
fans du talent et les sélections du tas
sont un peu bizarre quand même
c'est utah en fort oui georges était
combien de ce coin de [ __ ] ils ont du
coup de gérer le brantley ils ont les
aphtes et maillot ni les droits ne
jordan bonne le droit les à échanger oui
mais anne on a échangé pour avoir les
droits de douane c'est quoi cette suite
dray n'avait jamais investi et sous la
brise rose et juste il est donc faux
généreuse qui ont vous décrire ce qui se
passe il dit des 3a trade et pour avoir
les droits des jordan bonne de joe biden
qui n'a pas été drafté et avec qui ils
ont traîné
on sait pas mais que tu as fumé et il
est seulement la nuit et demi aux états
unis si et 6h30 cap adriano cup belle et
nous on s'en fout on veut d'elle et nord
dé on veut tacko fall et
[Musique]
59 et 60 s'en fout il ya eu celle 57
jordan bonne et s'est planté en plus il
sait pas et fermi o'neal aux biens ni
oui c'est 57 jordan bonne alexis qu'ils
sont des sources
j'écris j'écris milliers once ayez pas
les faits mais leoni manque de respects
manque de respect de ouf et virginia qui
place trois personnes dans la marée
noire ouais trois champions et qui ai
fait ça arrivera un et les organes sains
fait chanter à 6,55 non voilées il avait
57 quand je comprends sont rien moins
d'être achetés 57
je sais plus mais c'est quand même été
bougé ce soir à barzeh
je pensais le touquet van buyten et
n'importe quoi
non c'est la fin du bal quoi ah ouais
normal je sais pas je sais pas typique
même dans la salle il ya plus personne
chauncey billups il parle pour les
fantômes mais le guen organisé dans la
salle d'audience bah oui mais pas la
grinta new york à toronto ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup ça et là mais honni
non cydia l'aisne on regarde la photo la
haye les bouffes millet ont dit et du
coup il va où utah donc 18 ans ils sont
allés dont le dans le folklore et le 55
the ditch soit non jordan bonne aller
nous manque deux choix 3,3 choix non
deux fois donc il nous reste jon lord
il nous reste encore visionner les
courts tacko fall vibrer ses meilleurs
parmi les petits jeunes du gel j'amène
mes coups et et les chalets le quiou de
kew les critiques car les matthew james
a taxé de chenilles soual joueurs
disponibles brian bowen l'a énormément
de joueurs disponibles
un certain antoine bertrand chez ouais
mais balayés dit les gm est tous là ils
sont en train de sortir les téléphones
et de se dire allez vas-y on appelle les
agents d'aidé de ce qui m'embête drafté
la whey absolument clair c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer dans les
coulisses de la haine de la draft là à
brooklyn qui est en train de se
dépeupler espn qui nous montre comme
bijoux au be why wait et un projet
capillaire sera toujours est
exceptionnel intéressant messieurs on ne
peut le micro pokémon johnson en 11 ses
nerfs qui chacune kobe warynski qui ont
fait réagir de cameron sont bonnes et
son trait au web comme ça quand il a su
qu'il était drapé il
il a eu du mal à cacher sa surprise qui
était un petit peu plein de pas de v6
suffisent pas de et d'un effet prix
pourraient surprise dans la souffrance
qu absolument kobe white qui est on le
rappelle
drafté en 7 et qui va aller jouer pour
les bulls l'année prochaine elle pour
toi etienne celle là c'était encore en
ligne donc les fans et les promesses que
mathis taiwo l'avait c'était bien une
promesse de 6 heures quand prince prince
un moment mollon ton pote mollon ben pas
mon pote
mais bella j'ai besoin du pic 59 60 59
des one hernandez nous dit alexis jeu
parfois la vache taîwan hernandez d'ewan
hernandez c'est un petit peu un nom
d'acteur espagnol qui jouait dans une
baballe abeilles l'espagnol est bon ah
oui des one hernandez c'est un joueur
espagnol je serai qui jouait à miami
c'est vrai oui
post 4 et oui oui mais pourquoi prendre
au scrutin je viens de voir l'arrêt 4,5
et qui écarte mais des one hernandez
paraît gros tas feurs il a fait plein de
workout ça paye quoi voilà le travail
- joue un jeu qui ont passé le pic 60
du coup ceux qui se comptent neuf cd one
hernandez ou c'est et du coup on 50
certes on avait jordan bonne qui est
donc le meneur de tennessee le tennessee
et donc ça fait trois joueurs de tennis
et un alors pour le pic 57 et j'aime
bien dire de bonnes idées j'en tiens
ouais il est peu ce pas un méchant gamin
non non il est pas méchant
après il a tout fait théo ndèye coumba
tous les tests de athlétique
ouais mais il n'a jamais montré sur le
teint jamais montré que ça pouvait se
retranscrire sur un terrain non mais
mais voilà [ __ ] les pays qui ont su
perdre avec 60
donnez moi jen c'est le moment ou jamais
pour un dessin commence jamais commencé
justin robinson pas drafté multiair deal
avec les washington wizards multi arts
d'ille ouais ok avec du possible
garantie en plus
ouais bah bonne nouvelle une robinson
moi j'adore meneur backup de john wall
après ils ont thomas cet or en ski qui
part manière vais aussi jouer en l1 loïc
malard avec et je ne connais pas non
plus il s'appelle vania marinkovic ah
bah ça ça va marines kovic sont hachées
directement
ok mon pote vania et ça c'est un mec
qu'on verra jamais en nba
peut-être que je sais que je les ai vus
que comme le je sais que j'ai vu mais je
n'ai aucun souvenir
honnêtement j'en ai aucun sauna donc je
vais pas dire de la mairie pour f non je
n'ai pas dit je vais pas dire de
l'émergence de 15 à 6 on remercie el
viti vie qui twittait mieux que au
brochet way absolument marinkovic donc
nice méridia non sessa marine que ses
juges ouais alors il ya derrière costaud
ouais mais les serments non mais c'est
pas lui il a 30 ans va lui du coup ce
qui nous reste
n'importe quoi on a encore du jones est
porteur 22 ans marina bay beach il était
jeune il est serbe 1 99 86 kg et
visiblement il joua partisans
on a du terrain davis n'a pas été drafté
qui se va être très très courte alors
messieurs les plus hauts sur vos borde
la sur vos cordes à rennes 10e pas été
drafté balle with fing pour moi
clairement google docs le dors tu es au
lavage leader luis king kenny week-end
kennington pour moi merci
jay leno horde ci soit x tekken jeffries
dacquois jeffries absolument je les
arènes second fils tu choo john coyne
sharqaï boakai baumann saga ba konaté
junk en charge à maureillas owen
bouchama réponse très haut jared harper
jared harper in white web harry brown
ce triste si mich et ou [ __ ] le mec
s'est présenté à la draft com quels bons
choix et c'est les freshmen on en était
étonné que des hordes se présente comme
si mich et où quand et freshman soit est
drafté est dans le top 20 soit faite tu
viennes drafted d'abord c'est un peu
frustrant j'avoue pour mon coca on
s'attendait un peu horde
c'est un peu chaud sans dans la bien
aimé le revoir c'est clair mais bon il
va se faire il va se faire un chemin et
va faire autre chose ils y trouvent un
autre chemin pour lui qui va trouver un
chemin nba une un bilan hyper rapide ben
si tu devais donner une équipe qui sort
de cette draft grandi et avec une
nouvelle place dans la nba
car moi même jamais son image plus cher
le plus rapide plus agressive ouais moi
j'adore moi j'achète tâche est la draf
de memphis
on rappelle la drave de mon fils ben en
numéro deux à temps la mer
rent et un numéro 21 qui sont allés
chercher avec brandon clark con
j'aime qu'on m'a présenté pendant que de
nombreux scouting hip hop pardon comme
le deuxième jour le plus athlétique de
cette draft et et je crois que c'était
une cription plutôt adéquat
jq les gaziers signés pour 4,1 à félix
dans leur malheur
quatre ans antoine tombe à new york je
trouve qu'on s'en tire pas mal c'est
vrai alors gilbert est en trois sets
voilà perdus barrette plus que qu'ils
ont pris au piège après je dirais qu'ils
sont surtout les perdants est fini je
fais n'est phoenix là ils viennent de
signer les quais donc sur un contrat de
quatre ans
visiblement ils ont 15 passes dans leur
roster ils ont drafté plein de gamins
dont ne pas savoir quoi faire quand
johnson nickel alexander walker et ses
hommes n'ont ni quelles actions le rôle
coeur ses nouvelles rondeurs sa nouvelle
alliance est contre-indiqué pub sperme
mais j'en paye jérôme tels jérôme voilà
ils ont drafté pas mal de gens je sais
pas ce qu'il va en faire ici sinon on a
oublié aussi que des gens qui ont pas d
drafté charge de mathieu céliane cheese
and that will then chehab et ça fait
vraiment beaucoup de gens là les actifs
européenne sortez votre carnet
d'adressés clair ou alors écoutez nous
c'est clair et là il ya le pic 60 qui
est en train d'être annoncée manu toi
ton vainqueur de la draf c'est
évidemment l'équipe qui a draftés mallet
ionica non julian que j'aime bien
ouais même fils atlanta attend c'est le
bordel atlanta et dish a absolument
hayes
non non c'est une ola il c'est moi je
vois la meilleure draft celle des pays
qui nous entourent
c'est sans doute là je pourrai voir avec
une fois tout ou bien dealé avec tous
bien qu est-ce que ce couac semaine
signée avec les knicks ont tous aidé au
delà c'est bien les knicks ça si ça
signe direct toi moi je serai drafté
ropi que ça va tenir 60 sur un peu
dégoûté quoi et les mecs qu'ils
obtiennent des contrats directs yangon
attend on a les crocs encore c'est un
peu ridicule c'est la team envergure on
fait une photo et on se casse sans ben
ben tu es avec nous absolument vital et
peut-être qu'on avait pas défoncer les
télés
eh bien on coupe on coupe à l'élève à
mes veines proches beaucoup on est
désolés que tacko fall n'est pas été
drafté on sait que vous l'avait réclamé
peut-être qu'ils jouaient ne désespérez
pas de grandement possible et bonne nuit
et bonne visite
à lévis attends je vais je vais arrêter
la diffusion je veux arrêter
[Musique]
pourquoi je peux va l'arrêter
tu peux demander la pole de l'arrêter
balleux la retransmission à la vache à
lait